isations
mode
more
I'm gonna add a pyramid thingy.
Bob Ma!
Oh god!
I've got something to show you!
Bye bye.
That's pretty.
She hates the intro street.
I mean...
I hate it.
Momma!
Good morning, good evening, good afternoon!
You know how I said I'm a rather quite a lucky person?
Yeah.
I accidentally became the first video on Acapella Media's YouTube channel.
This wasn't planned.
None of this was like a behind the scenes ploy or anything like that.
I literally flapped my gums about the interview stage that we had with them,
because we had an interview with them.
And then I accidentally became the first video on their channel.
What?
The audios for Midsma were really cute.
Did you guys see that?
If you didn't know, I just did a birthday call in with Midsma.
I've never done one before.
So I didn't know what to do or what to expect.
But I just called upon the girls and I said,
darlings, if you can send me an audio, just a view saying happy birthday to Midsma.
And if you've got a question for her, let me know because
I kind of assumed Midsma's been streaming for three days now.
I went out on a limb and said, she's probably exhausted
and she doesn't want to think anymore.
And she doesn't want to have to kind of steer the conversation.
So I was like, you know, I'm cracking my knuckles.
I'm right, right.
I'll take over this.
Don't you worry.
I'll take this over.
So I gave her those questions and I also gave her those audios.
And then I excused myself and it was a cute little view.
Vealer takes care of other content creators challenge.
No, you know what it should be.
Vealer doesn't take care of other content creators challenge impossible.
Sheebie was saying I was helping out
one of the girls, a girl that isn't mine behind the scenes.
And, you know, I told Sheebie about the situation and she was like,
you actually can help yourself.
Can you?
And I'm like, no, I can't if someone needs help.
I'm like, here, this is what you do.
This is how you can make it super simple.
You just get straight to the point.
Vealer colonize and other features.
That's funny.
That's terrible.
But that's not the only thing I want to show you.
Because if you didn't notice the end of the week,
and what does it mean when it's the end of the week?
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, hold on.
Right, there we go.
I am collabing with
Now, unfortunately,
Dead by Daylight has a temporary
two killers versus
eight
survivors.
Now, I thought we could do a stream snip lobby.
This is how you say in French,
no fucking possible.
So it's not really going to work with that,
but I've got two hours with my beloved
sister.
Then I'm doing a member's ASMR
where I'm doing a thousand kisses,
and I'm not allowed to speak
until I've done a thousand kisses,
because for those of you who don't know,
whenever I do a membership ASMR stream,
I never ever actually do ASMR.
I always end up starting yapping away
and ruining the experience.
So as punishment, we're doing that.
I'm doing a collab with
none other than Aysa Cole.
We're playing Escape Simulator.
She's a bit nervous, but I told her,
so she hasn't played it.
I have played it.
I told her, hey, don't you worry.
I'll get you through it.
Then you mind.
Bleeding, refling Senpai.
That's so good.
Just smashing them all together.
Thank you for the super chat.
How did I say the gear?
I don't know.
I can't remember.
Is it Vegeta or Vegeta?
Oh, I said, I can't even remember.
And I was like, oh, is that Goku?
And everyone was like, oh, my God.
Shut up, Strony.
And I'm like, oh, no, no, no.
Not Vegeta.
You said it wrong again.
Vegeta, that's how it's spelled.
Okay.
The members watch along.
Oh, you convinced me.
We're watching Hercules after Beauty and the Beast.
Oh, I'm convinced.
I'm sorry.
I was just, I had to.
That's the stream, which is,
I'm going to be answering questions
that you are too afraid to ask.
Now, you can use my marshmallows to ask
some questions that you're too afraid to ask.
But I will have some pre-made questions as well
that we will be answering.
Goku.
Yeah, literally, that's how to say it.
I love how you pronounce it.
It's pronounced like that.
Turnip boy commits tax evasion.
This game, I have heard about it.
I've heard whispers about it.
I've heard so much about the dang thing.
We're going to finally do it, okay?
Now, I do love a bit of tax evasion.
That's terrible.
I don't know where I was going with that.
I was going to make a joke, but I'm not really
woken up yet.
So, yeah.
Then we're going to finish.
We are officially going to get Old School Runes,
my first ever cape, okay?
Implying there might be more.
I don't know yet.
But right now, we are going to polish off
our little Old School Runescape series.
And then I am playing another collab.
So, I've got a collab with Sin Sister,
I've got a collab with Asakul,
I've got a collab with Arissa.
We're going to be playing this really cute game
on Xbox Game Pass.
It's called Moving Out 2.
I've never played it.
It looks like one of those games
that you can just pick up really quickly.
So, I don't need to hunt around the internet
for how to play guide or anything like that.
So, you'll get to meet Arissa.
She is the fantastic brains and brawn
behind the shorts you see on my YouTube channel.
The first two shorts on my channel
are very clearly edited by me.
And then after that, nothing's done by me.
Nothing.
I'm going to turn down the audio.
70M audio.
Unless it's just loud on my headset,
I'm not sure.
But it is.
And then on Saturday,
our StreamSnipe game is vermin tight 2.
Now, I am going to make a throwaway steam account.
So, we can play steam games together
where I add you.
And then at the end of stream,
I will prove that I have removed absolutely everyone.
But I am going to boot up their vermin tight.
I've not played it in a very, very long time.
The game music is really adding
to the intensity of the schedule reveal.
Honestly.
Love me some vermin tight.
Oh, yeah.
It's Saturday.
What does that mean?
Sounds like Rotterdam.
And vermin tight 2 with DLCs.
I don't.
I think just base game.
I don't remember purchasing the DLCs many months ago.
But, yeah.
Haven't played vermin tight in a while.
Halo music, my beloved.
And then for celebrating 15,000 subscribers
on Strongly Cuts channel.
Bum, bum, bum.
We are going to do a thigh,
cam,
ASMR stream.
Everyone can access it.
So, don't you worry.
And then members writing stream for my gen mates.
I...
So...
Yeah.
We'll figure it out.
I don't know if I'll go back to the one-on-one collabs or whatever.
Celebration for 15k and your 200 subs off 20k.
No, I need to...
Well, so the 20k celebration stream is 20k already?
No, no.
I don't know if I'll go back to the channel.
That would have jumped like a stupendous amount in the middle of the night.
It says I've got 19,837.
Yeah, I was going to say that would have been a big jump.
Um...
Yeah.
Also, you guys are all in trouble for misleading me.
I thought we were winning on Fortnite,
but we were against bots the whole time.
I thought we were against real people.
I thought I was just so excited.
Stop!
I like how Nani just crushed it until it kind of dawned on me.
I literally...
You're discovering it only now.
So, at the end of the stream, I kind of figured it out.
But I started going apeshit on our first victory royale together.
Because I was like, oh my god!
We did it, we did it.
And all of you were like, oh my god, she's so happy.
Let's not ruin the fact that she's against bots.
Um...
There were definitely some real people.
Trust us, players feel real, literally.
Um...
The Lego Lord of the Ring streams are going to go back up
once I am happy that I'm not going to get DMC'd
and the channel is going to be nuked into oblivion.
All of the bots for Lego Lord of the Rings got...
Um...
Got...
Heavily copyrighted because of the campaign mode.
All the music is straight out from the movie franchise.
And I kid you not, I think OneVod has over 50 claims.
And I'm like, oh, that's enough to get your channel deleted.
So a private edit for now.
There were at least three real players in the game, honestly.
Halo adds much dramatically.
When you love Lord of the Rings but doesn't love you back.
I can't believe Peter Jackson literally hasn't given me the rights to the entire franchise.
Like...
Warner Brothers, step your game up.
I'm waiting for the letter to say that I have a free ride on everything.
It's a lot of claims, like it's scary.
Like, so my, like Assassin's Creed has a claim.
A few random games have a claim here and there.
They're like false.
They'll go away eventually, but yeah.
You're not telling me that bullet that hit my skull wasn't shot by a real person.
But yes, that is today's, today's.
That's the week schedule.
Everything is on time, the usual time that I stream.
Except for Escape Simulator with AC.
Whenever I collab with a gen mate, I will pick their usual time slot.
Just because I don't want to rock the boat.
Rock the boat baby, rock the boat.
So I am two hours early with me and Icicle.
But I think since sister is fine with me doing my thing.
Eryssa Nunesh is actually quite a lot later.
So we're going to get old school runescape.
Apparently it's four hours of yapping and then we got, we get the cape.
And then I go offline for a chunk and then I come back online with Eryssa because Eryssa is Aussie.
But I couldn't be like, do you want to wake up at 4 a.m. with me?
No, I cannot fucking ask an Aussie to wake up at 4 a.m.
So yeah.
Yeah, Dead by Daily is like 6% off at the moment if anyone was thinking about getting it too.
Yes, unfortunately there's no direct way to stream snipe.
It's just lobby luck.
But yeah.
Thank you Dimpa Fish for the artwork.
I love the big shells.
Like I love the art style of like just I'm so kawaii-nee.
Don't think I won't edit an ear cleaning tool in my hand and make that an ASMR thumbnail.
Don't think I won't do it Eryssa because I'll do it.
Yeah, Eryssa.
Dimpa because I'll do it.
Aren't you streaming at 2 a.m.?
I stream at 4 a.m. my time.
I'm streaming at 2 a.m. with Icicle.
But for any snowberries lurking in the shadows, I do have fantastic news for you.
I recorded the missing folly sounds for a YouTube role play that's going to go up on A.C.'s channel.
Now, depending on how much energy I have by the end of this stream, there may or may not be a little A.C.icle thing going on.
I am communicating.
A.C. is hoping to have a few more shorts come up and common vermentide dove reel.
Literally, what a stream snip game.
Fucking vermentide of all of them.
But yes, for vermentide, I am going to make a throwaway steam account that we purposefully use for stream sniping things.
And at the end, just for anyone that has brain worms, please don't worry.
I've got you in my back pocket.
I'm thinking about you just as much as you're thinking about me.
I was having a really tough time yesterday.
And I was listening to this Oliver Tree song and I was going to tweet it out and I'm like,
wait, no, that's negative post and I'm not because I don't want to upset anyone.
But I was listening to the song and I wanted to buy a billion artworks of me and you together just to be like,
I'm so thankful for you, just being so nice to me.
I had to tinker with the bios of a new PZ where you shit in your pantylons updating that thing.
Your streaming schedule is clapped.
Wait, what does that mean?
Your streaming schedule is clapped?
What happened?
What does it mean?
It got an STD?
It's clapped goods?
The only thing clapped is my cheeks after a good stream by you guys.
You get a good stream sniping event.
You go plop plop plop.
My man plop plop plop.
He's speaking Zimmerman.
The new emotes are highlighted.
Oh no, those aren't.
Well, they're emote holders.
I'm getting deja vu.
I've been in this place before.
Hire on the streets and it's not on my time to go.
I don't know the words.
Clapped equals clapped the cheek as in get ripped.
Yeah, that's the other thing.
I wish to hear them clap.
I mean, for 20k subs, I'm doing a picture on my alt Twitter,
but I might do a gif as well of my actual, like, you know...
Oh wait, no, you wouldn't be able to hear it.
Okay, maybe I'll just do a twerk gif.
I'll do a gif of twerking.
I'll do thank you for 20k picture.
And if I can get it on video, like what it looks like when my cheeks are clapping,
then I'll post it.
So I'm not sure what I'm doing.
Quite everyone gets a twerk gif.
A round of applause.
So, em, I will say tactically, em, this week's streams,
some of them are a lot shorter than the usual, like,
first day's four hours, second day's four hours,
third day is a two hour stream.
Apparently, turn it boys like three hours.
I was gonna play that potion shop game,
but I decided against it because it's a quite mine.
I need to somehow summon 200 people right now.
I wish I could summon more than one.
No, no, don't worry.
I will gif some of the subs.
No, no, no, no, no, those kind of subs,
just like general channel subscribers.
If I had 20,000, like, membership thingies,
bro, Gen 2 and 3 would be farted out more.
Em, but old school runescape is four hours,
then offline, then back online,
and then vermentage.
As long as everyone who wants to play with me has played,
then I'm quite satisfied when we, like, wrap up at that point.
Em, and then thai cami, samar, you know,
it may just be an hour stream, hour and a half.
Two hours of rubbing my thighs on the make.
I feel like the concept gets a bit stale real quick, you know?
I'm still waiting for emmy's oiled up toes though.
Where the fuck are they?
Where are they?
I mean, we're waiting.
She thought that I wasn't going to ask for the oiled up feet?
No.
Going to play Halo Master?
Yay.
We're going to play Anniversary.
Hold on, let me pop that way.
Okay, now whatever's our shared plan,
we're going to do a combat evolve.
Now, this game my dad used to...
Oh, my dad's message, hold on.
I'm going to finally read...
So I didn't realise how much I'm going to have to paraphrase
what my dad said.
Hold on, let me open it up,
because I have to write it down in Discord.
Right, this is from Papacuttle's.
Okay, this is from Papacuttle's.
Now, I had to change in the fucking...
because obviously legal name here, legal address here,
legal this and that.
He was...
Thank you for being there for my daughter when I could not.
It's been hard being so far from her
after everything that happened,
but it's nice to know you have each other's back.
She has waited very long and worked very hard
to come back to you,
and all seems to be well,
so please continue to enjoy your time together.
She explained that you're now refling,
which I think is a good fit.
And then he ended it with Papacuttle's approves,
because I was saying the approves message.
Now, I did have to remove a few things,
because obviously there's legal name, this, legal name, that,
and I'm like, right, steady on, steady on, steady on.
Enough of the legal name.
Yeah.
We've got his approval.
Wait, I'm getting emotional.
No, so my dad,
with what happened last year,
obviously my dad couldn't be with me.
And I was going through a very hard time,
like I completely relapsed in my A-bomb and all that,
like I'm back on,
I mean, not to get like fucking dramatic or anything,
but like I'm back on my A-bomb medication,
because I never used to have to take it,
but now I have to go back on it type thing.
Yeah.
And he was obviously very worried,
because when I used to be on it,
that's when I was locked in the house for two years,
and he was like, oh my God, what's happening with you?
But he couldn't come over,
I mean, he couldn't see me, so, yeah.
But I was expecting the feels for Halo,
but that's my heart can't take it.
He's going good,
and we're playing Halo Combat Evolved.
Now that we have your dad's blessing, let's get married.
If you keep enough of your Marines alive,
you get a lot of respect.
Subbed because of it, just saying, what does that mean?
Wait, I get like accolades in game?
Are you teaching me something, yeah?
We have to give Boombay a hug.
Are you playing with the original graphics?
I don't know, what do you guys want?
It's up to you.
Oh, let me just pick legendary.
Achoo!
Okay, we picked legendary.
Okay, are we ready?
So, my dad replayed this game
all the time in front of me,
but I used to be terrified of the grunts,
or the wee aliens,
and I used to hide behind the couch.
Did the original graphics remaster suck?
Do you know what else sucks?
You on my boobay.
Legendary, cut off if it still be.
I don't even know how to...
Arsenic!
Why are you named after Poison?
Cos you're Poison!
Thank you for becoming a member, Arsenic.
Enjoy the emotes.
Sorry about the pregnancy one.
I promise I'm ordering the actual real emotes soon to you.
Press Tab to switch graphics.
Telling me to skip, which I don't want to.
Is this too quiet?
Do not remove the pregnant one?
Can at least make it...
Spoiler alert, good luck.
We are playing legendary difficulty.
I need to push up.
This is so quiet, what the fuck.
Oh, I've got it on ASMR.
At light speed, my maneuvering options were limited.
Is that better?
Yes.
Until we decelerated, no one could have missed the hole we tore in subspace.
A video of clapping will use in prayer beats?
On main?
They were waiting for us on the far side of the planet.
It's railed up this morning, clearly.
Our fighters are mopping up the last of the recon picket now, nothing serious.
Legendary.
But I've isolated approach signatures for multiple CCS class battle groups.
Sorry, AVW, thank you for coming to memory.
This game is quiet, right?
Where is it me?
Press Tab.
I'm pressing Tab, but it's not registered enough.
Nothing's changing.
Cortana!
I want to get one more.
Volume seems fine.
It is quiet, I don't know if it's bad things.
It can change.
Remember that time I played Heal of Wars online and I died instantly?
I've still never forgiven myself for being such a dumbass.
DUMBASS!
Mommy, he's trying to fuck us.
Yes, I will.
You heard the lady.
Move like you got a purpose.
This is not a thrill.
I repeat, this is not a thrill.
Man, your eyes down range.
Fingers on your triggers.
And we all go home in one ditch.
Fingers on your trigger?
Am I right, Ray?
Wait, no, you're not...
Sir, yes, sir!
Damn right I am.
Now move it out!
Double time!
Attention all personnel.
We are re-engaging the enemy.
External and internal contact imminent.
All you greenhorns who wanted to see covenant up close.
This is going to be your lucky day.
Cortana, one croak.
Sir?
Is that John Master Chief Halo from the hit video game Fortnite?
Okay.
Bringing low-level systems online.
No trigger.
Tracking the case in 30 seconds.
Safety measures are off.
Other regios with fingers.
Oh my god, it's...
Reflings down the cryo!
It's time to party!
Party, party, party, party, party, party.
You've waited long enough.
Let's go!
I'm playing...
I'm playing a controller.
Hold on.
Orientation.
One second mate.
One second.
How did I even do that?
Where the fuck are subtitles?
You guys are seeing the volumes a little bit.
We're accessibility.
Wait.
Subtitles were on?
Why aren't you even lying?
Sorry.
I guess that was burning inside.
Subtitle setting.
No, that's fine.
Yeah, that's fine.
Put it on.
Sorry.
That echo.
I was like, I didn't...
Yeah, I see.
Right, and I put it up a bit.
I'm joined in at the right time.
Right, so...
I'm going to tell you something.
Where are my subtitles?
Did I not just put them on?
It's not on.
Accessibility.
Automatic.
Off.
On.
Off a fuck's sake.
Right.
I.
Gee.
Vital signs look normal.
It's done.
No freezer burn.
Okay, sir.
Go ahead and climb out of the cryo tube.
Use rate bumper.
I'm blinded.
Let me tell you something.
Automatic is not on.
I gave you a double dose of the wake-up stim.
Take a quick walk around the cryo bay
and join me at the optical diagnostic station
when you're ready.
Okay.
Wait.
Oh, my God.
That's the difference.
All right.
Oh, my God.
Holy.
Right.
Okay.
Let me...
I guess we're playing old school.
Right.
Do you want me to play most in keyboard?
Are you okay with...
Where the fuck am I going?
Is there the door?
Wait.
Where the fuck am I supposed to go?
Oh, my God.
Dad, I need help.
Dad!
Maybe I'll just do most in keyboard.
I can't see him.
Am I going mental?
Can you guys see that?
Wait.
Why the fuck is this inverted?
Why is this inverted?
Don't do that.
Stop it.
Why is it inverted now?
Oh, my God.
Stop.
You're making me look like a fool.
Is that better?
Should I switch it back?
No.
The other...
What the fuck?
Why would anyone play inverted?
What's cycle?
It's something...
Why?
Oh, he said there's an error.
Oh, right.
Sorry, that was actually another creative of the dev team.
I'm sorry, dev team.
You can change it yourself later.
I can hardly see...
I literally...
I'm sorry.
I literally cannot see you.
Please let me put up the brightness.
Because...
What the fuck?
Put up that fucking gamma.
How can I see function?
Wait.
Let's go.
I'm ready for the energy shield test now.
Please follow me to the energy shield test station.
What?
Oh, UI gamma?
No.
What the fuck's that?
Hold on.
Scuff, scuff.
I know how to do that.
Gamma!
Put that fucking up so I can bloody see!
And now everything's cloudy.
I can't even fucking see.
Oh, it's a door.
No.
How do I run into this guy?
Stand on the yellow square.
This will just take a second.
Oh, I'm just putting my...
Okay, bring his energy shields online, please.
What the heck has been on the door?
I have no idea.
It's so dark for me as well.
Alright.
Shield read is fully charged.
Okay, sir.
Bring them down to test the automatic green charge.
Is it brighter on the other graphic?
Well, I can certainly steal all better
with the other graphic left admit,
so it must just be this area.
Press E to continue.
Ow!
Give me my shield back.
Color blank.
There's no...
Wait, there's no sprint?
Captain, we'll have to skip the weapons diagnostics, and I...
This game is so old,
the skipper seems jumpy,
we better get moving.
We'll find you weapons later.
Oh, my God!
I forgot!
I was like two years old
watching my dad replay this game.
This way.
Can I get a gun, please?
The true authentic experience.
Oh, my God!
Am I skinny enough for this?
No, I'm not skinny enough.
Oh, my God!
Ow!
Why are you so loud out of nowhere?
Right.
One, relax.
Two, go down.
What the fuck?
That went so loud out of nowhere.
Game music.
Man, your music.
Get that shakedown.
Save.
Okay, let's try that.
Loud Halo theme, please.
That is still really fucking loud.
Holy shit, hold on.
How is...
Okay, I think...
I don't know.
I can lower it further.
No sprint and climbing.
Okay.
I'm like looking at the bar
versus me, and it's not looking good.
Banger is a banger,
but it's so loud.
Oh, they're dying.
Can I carry this weapon?
Can I have your pistol, please?
Oh!
I'm actually getting shot at.
Can I get your pistol, please?
Ah!
What did I do?
I don't have a gun.
I don't have anything.
Please.
Anyone?
Can you give me your pistol?
Uh, yeah.
I can't see anything.
I think...
I can see more on OBS
than I am on my actual screen.
I'm glad you're playing Halo's.
Bro, give me your gun!
Give me your gun!
Yeah, it's him.
Fuck it.
Joe Bonogos, Johnny's husband.
Thank you for the super chat.
I'm trying to play it,
but I don't remember anything.
I just remember my dad playing the first mission
where they crash landed
and everyone died in the ship.
I'm starting to think it's not this game.
I'm getting nervous.
I don't think I'm playing the right one
that my dad played.
Is this not the one where you crash down in the ship?
Give me a weapon!
Get clear!
No!
Give me freakin' ammo!
It's because colorblind mode is on?
Wait, actually?
Are you trolling me?
Accessibility?
Colorblind?
UI colorblindness, colorblindness.
Why was that even on?
I can see!
I can see now.
I can see.
Oh my god.
Well, I'm blinded now, but...
Why was that on?
Did I put it on?
I thought you had.
Bro.
Put it on when I was going to fail.
10 out of 10.
Smash!
Don't care.
I love Cortana so much.
Can you imagine how much they...
in the helmet?
Report.
It would.
Ma'am!
Fire control for the main cannon is offline!
Captain, the cannon was my last offensive option.
All right.
I'm initiating cold protocol article 2.
We're abandoning the autumn.
That means you too, Cortana.
Why did you go down the ship?
It doesn't let me, but I'm going to leave the old stuff on.
I'm going to try and land the autumn on it.
AI decided what they looked like, so Cortana decided to do it like this.
He was a sexist woman.
I appreciate your concern, Cortana.
But it's not a thing.
That skin tight bodysuit.
Cortana Gen 2, confirm.
Instruction or capture of a ship...
Shontana!
Oh, it kind of sounds like Hannah Montana.
You already know what chief collapses?
She's digitally real and true.
I'm sorry, but...
I may or may not have consumed some Cortana stuff back in the past,
because I love her so much.
Absolutely accept otherwise.
I always thought she was just...
Her.
I understand.
The autumn will continue evasive maneuvers
until you initiate a landing sequence.
Not that you'll listen, but I'd suggest letting my subroutines
handle the final approach.
Excellent work, Cortana.
I can't.
Back then, the animation was just the jaw unhinging.
A calendar.
Shontana and master calls.
Stop! I'll order that artwork right now.
I was like sewing my feels yesterday.
I'm like, okay, I'm going to order all this artwork
and it's going to make me feel so much better.
And it was artwork of me being like,
thank you for waiting on me type stuff.
Your architecture isn't much different from the others.
Oh my god, she's in my...
In my head!
Okay.
There's a lady in my head
that calls me stud muffin.
Maybe I should get one of me as Cortana
and I'm taking you out of cryo-freeze.
I think maybe that one would be quite significant.
Oh my god, I can actually see.
I cannot tell you how much I can see.
Oh my god.
Look at that legendary mode skills.
Oh!
That's right, I'm on legendary mode.
Oh, hold on, I need reload.
Oh my god, the aim assist is like so strong.
I love it.
Oh my god, we're in the mess hole.
Oh my god, the aim assist is still good.
Is it still loud or anything?
Sorry.
Oh my god, I love it.
How do I eat an alien this game?
Bravo.
How do you reload?
Wait, X is in reload?
What the fuck is reload?
How do you...
How do you re-
Wait, how?
Right bumper is to reload?
Stop.
That's terrible.
I'm not sure when we're going to be reloading
in a lot of middle of things.
Right.
Right bumper, honestly.
Oh wait, hold on, I already...
Wait, hold on, I need reload.
Right, okay, there we go, there we go.
Oh, the controls popping up
just as I'm having a stroke.
Try to figure out how to reload that.
Oh, wait, that's not right.
How do you like it now?
It's nothing, it's airlock.
Airlock?
In my...
Oh, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna...
I'm not gonna lie, I almost shot at them.
Stop, I love the aim assist in this game so much.
I love not having to try hard in games.
Amy messaged me yesterday.
She was like, oh, did you have fun on Fortnite?
And I was like, yeah.
I was telling her like,
oh, I really enjoy not having to like...
Is that just because you're alien technology?
Wait, we better just smash it.
Huh?
It's like a bonus or something.
I don't know, I've just done something.
Overshield?
Wait, is this actually legendary?
Yeah, yeah, no, this is legendary.
100%, yep.
MLG Pro, that's me.
See, the thing with trying to win legendary mode
is you have to hit your headshots
or you're just wasting bullets unironically
playing this game mode.
So don't waste your bullets and aim for the head.
See how I'm carefully aligning the crosshair for the head.
It just means that...
And you can fill the AI as well
because if you didn't know, when you look away from the AI
it's programmed not to shoot you
but as you can see, like all these headshots,
you can't get me.
Such a pro.
But I know all the strats and I'll just be running.
Do you guys remember
that guy that pretended to be a Halo player
and he was like speedrunning
but he wasn't really a Halo player?
And he played this game
and he was like messing up all the strats
and he was invited to do it on Games Done Quick.
She's just pro-game of the best, literally.
As I just sort of shoot my own ally.
Oh my god, Amy says, come on, pop off.
Hold up.
Wait, I keep...
I keep putting the flashlight on to freaking reload.
Right, hold on.
Gameplay, no.
Controls.
Configure the gamepad.
Reload.
Rit, rit.
Oh no.
Do not invert anything.
Oh my gosh.
Edit layout.
Reload.
X.
Flashlight.
Sure.
I'll just shove on that.
What do you mean, action?
Do we even need the flashlight?
Be honest.
I don't know.
Save changes.
There's one unmapped.
Well, where does it go?
No, don't...
No, that's jump.
Oh my god, the game's trolling me.
Right, Crouch actually should be that one.
Zoom in.
Wait, so what's the missing...
The game's trolling me.
I don't know what the missing input is.
Missing input.
Toggle the flashlight.
Just put on X as well, then, I guess.
Or is it going to take it off?
Wait, I'm getting trolled.
I'm actually getting trolled.
I'm getting trolled.
Please use the pre-made one.
I'm fucking...
I'm just having to restore it.
Discard changes.
Bruh, I'm actually going to have a stroke playing this game.
Oh my god.
Right, I'm just going to have to...
Wait, why can't I shoot?
Hold up.
What have I done?
I literally cannot shoot.
Configure game path.
What have I done?
Shoot.
Fire.
Right trigger.
Right, so why was...
What have I done?
What?!
Huh?!
Configure...
Oh my god, what is going on?!
Right, you know what?
You know what?
I don't know what's going on.
We're fucking...
We're just doing mouse and keyboard.
I don't know what's going on.
It's just too embarrassing to continue.
Okay, this is too embarrassing to continue with the game pad.
I've absolutely...
I've broken everything.
I have broken everything.
And are you doing the rest of it?
Wait.
Whoa!
Okay, we just had a massive lag spike.
That's okay.
Wait, where is that supposed to go?
Right here?
Can you...
Yeah, okay, okay.
At least mouse and keyboard seem to be the correct kind of thing.
As I said, I am a legendary player,
so I can handle these kind of major inconveniences.
As you can see...
I'm just so good.
I don't know what happened.
Please back off.
You're so...
I broke the game.
Literally, the game thought...
Why does it keep doing that?
It keeps, like, stopping me from walking.
It keeps, like, stuttering.
What are you...
It's like...
Oh my god!
How have I done this?
What have I done to make this happen?
I covered it.
On the landing above us.
It's, like, stuttering the game now?
Because I swapped some controls around by accident?
I'm now, like, got insane free-rate lag or something?
The graphics are a pixel!
I don't know.
It's impressed how bad...
How badly you broke it so quickly.
Look, the game is obviously trying to sabotage me.
What the fuck is this?
What is this?
What did I do with it?
Did I touch it?
What did it do?
How about it's melee?
I don't know.
Murph for melee?
Oh my god.
Everything's lagging.
I don't know.
Oh my god.
It keeps, like, pausing me.
I don't know why.
I can't do this.
I've missed this so badly.
You have to put it on a different present,
like, South 4.
Also, I think...
Click the analog stick and flashlight.
It's an animal.
And plug the controller and hit the golden dodo.
Wait, actually.
The controller's fucking wireless.
It's connected.
No!
Don't change the graphics!
I never even touched the button!
How could this go so amiss?
POV when girls think they're gamers.
Fuck you.
I've taken out the controller.
That was my PC that made that noise.
I've taken out the controller,
so it only has the keyboard input.
Let's see if that'll fix my random
starting and stopping.
I'm to go back and melee the crap out of this.
This is primes...
I've never had a stream go so badly before.
What is going on?
I'm to do something with this.
Melee, obviously, should be my mouse button.
Let's skip down a bit.
Hold on, hold on.
You've been in the game for so long,
and you've not even...
Melee.
What?
Mouse for...
That's all I need.
Everything else?
I'm just...
I'm not touching my 10 foot pool.
Nothing happens.
Are you trolling me?
Rest well, those who need to sleep.
Shoot it.
Oh!
It says I spy one of three.
Ha!
You're in my way, bro.
Bro!
You're literally blocking me.
I, Master Chief, the tank.
Okay.
I spy.
I didn't even know those were in the game.
Or we don't mean...
Okay, we'll play moose and keyboard,
because we're just...
Oh my god, is that an empty thing?
Sorry, Cortana.
I was having to deal with my sentence,
but thank you, though.
Oh, can they get a little freight?
They're like, whew!
Oh, I went too far.
I don't know.
That looks like maintenance to me.
Master Chief, more like a Master Chief.
Heller of all of them,
this mission has a maximum of, like,
Wait, they're randomized?
I've been trolled.
Did it really just make me walk through this tunnel
and there's nothing in it?
Oh.
Press four or use a flashlight.
Okay, okay.
I literally thought it was like,
yeah, go down this tunnel,
but it's not gonna go anywhere.
Ooh!
Let me in!
Okay, again, just a random place.
Uh-huh.
Okay, we've learned melee.
I do a lot of good tutorial mode.
Cortana, we need some mad help.
Mad help.
Oh, my God, so good.
As if you take a full magazine clip
to go down, Saus.
He's not that much of a tank.
Mummy's strong.
Literally, I am matrixing the bullets.
I'm matrixing them so hard right now.
Right, I think...
I think we're over our issues.
Okay, I think the issues are over.
Oh, my God, it's me!
Oh, wait, no.
No, it's you!
Wait, hold on.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Hold on, pause, pause, pause.
Let me redo that clip.
Let me redo the clip.
Hold on, hold on.
Let me redo it.
Okay.
Okay, I think we've dealt with
all the problems now
with the controls.
Oh, my God, it's Sherry!
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Thank you, refunds.
Okay, my voice feels better.
Oh, shit.
Is there all going to blow it up to smithereens?
You're going to gulp in yourself
this crazy work, honestly.
Wait, am I...
Can I die here?
Can I actually die here?
Wait, where's my flashlight dead?
I can't see anything.
Oh, my God, that scared me.
Don't do that.
My freaking flashlight doesn't have
full bars.
Why put me in a dark room
if it's freaking going to put...
This isn't a horror game.
Stop it.
Don't laugh.
Don't laugh, okay?
Put me in a dark place
and then put a jump scare in.
It's loud, okay?
I didn't expect them.
I get creeped out when there's things
rattling around and...
Oh, my God.
Don't do that again, Halo.
You understand me?
Don't jump scare me again.
Cannon fodder.
This is a lot of corridors.
Where?
Where is it?
I don't know where it is.
I swear if I die,
because I can't figure out
where this launch thing is.
This one?
This one.
Okay, we made it.
Okay.
This?
Yay!
I had a right to check.
Going for minimum safe distance?
That's really good.
Oh, Dim's done.
Thank you for the tip.
I'm so sorry.
I'll do a mouse and keyboard.
I'm good with mouse and keyboard.
Amy has sent me a DM.
Are you squidding me right now?
Tharya!
That's actually really good.
I'm going to give you that one.
Thank you, Tharya, for the super chat.
That was actually a really good one.
That was quick.
Not going to lie.
I went past the lifeboat twice.
We're going to make it, sir.
I don't want to die.
No, you don't have armor, mate.
I don't know in full world.
But don't worry, your sheep can be clocked.
Narrative Navigator 1 of 8.
The AI kept jumping off the bridge,
so Bungie just killed them to not go programming.
That's so real.
I'm losing her.
Brace for impact.
Oh, no.
Oh, lord.
Are we in the heaven?
Chief?
Chief, can you hear me?
This is what I remember my dad playing.
Are you all right?
Can you move?
Oh, my god.
What are we picking up?
Oh, ammo and spook.
Okay.
I think I have all the ammo in me.
Yeah!
Damn!
There's a sacrifice.
I...
killed Joan.
He's really clinic.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Need me more than American Henry accent.
I don't know what you're talking about.
They all say us Marines are the exact same.
They all call us jarheads.
They all say we chew crayons.
That's not what I found.
We are the...
I don't know.
I don't have...
Alert.
Why did she say that so sassily?
Halo.
Mr. Halo.
Alert.
There's enemies.
Can you just like walk away from the fight
if the direction of the mission is over here?
Can I just walk away?
What's that noise?
I've literally just walked away.
There's something by the waterfall.
Really?
There's a rather loud...
Do you mean?
Okay.
These things are loud.
Is there actually something at the waterfall?
Drap.
Is there actually...
Before I go down here,
is there actually or am I getting trolled?
I can hear stuff.
A skull?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I thought John Chief doesn't take fall damage.
Where the fuck is my skull?
Did you just make me take...
Mods, time that man out.
Where the fuck is the skull?
He doesn't take it in the other game.
I'm such a fake gamer.
Time out.
Anyone who said there was something behind the waterfall?
Mods, time them out for 10 seconds.
That'll teach them to think twice before speaking
in such...
Only in the new graphics.
Wait, what?
There's a skull behind the new graphics?
Why would there be a skull behind the new?
I can't even see!
You're too low of a difficulty.
These accusations are unfound.
I'm on legendary mode.
The skull is on new graphics.
On a higher difficulty getty!
Fuck, man.
No.
I'm already on legendary.
You literally can't get better than me.
Oh, this is your start, make a wish.
Are you kidding me?
Yeah.
It really has a bull, hasn't it?
Thank you, tiny spiny.
Difficulties shouldn't matter.
That's impossible.
She's on the highest difficulty.
Thank you.
Alright, then.
I don't deserve to take...
No!
Oh, no, we actually have to do the fight now.
How do I get more health out of this?
I genuinely don't know.
I can hear it.
By the way, if you hear a heartbeat,
it's because I'm one health.
Right, let's try that again.
Let's try that again.
Hold on now, hold on now.
Hold on now.
Look, as I said, we're on legendary difficulty.
The only way the game can kill me
is if I give myself fall damage.
I basically have to sabotage myself, okay?
Okay.
I literally am the only reason I die in video games
because I'm naturally so good at them, you know?
I'm naturally...
Death counter one...
No!
Wait, what?
How am I getting shot?
The booty lord?
War.
War never changes.
No, the thing's on fire.
Fuck it out!
Fuck it out, where's the other one?
Okay.
There's grunts on the hill.
I repeat, there's wee aliens on the hill.
Whose side are you on?
Are you on Jenna's side or are you on the alien's side?
I'm trying to make a joke about killing the aliens.
I'm sorry, it's not working.
I'm sorry.
I am not smart enough to pull off that joke.
Right.
The pistol is the greatest sniper, is it actually?
How do I swap to my second gun?
Oh, there we go.
Okay, let's snipe some people.
I'm on the side of justice, bonk!
Okay, I'm creepy indeed.
Okay, let's see if I'm any good with the sniper.
You didn't see that.
Okay, hold on.
I just found getting shot.
Wait, I'm killing the dead body, they're already dead.
Who is she?
Oh my god, look at that inboard.
Come on, come on.
You have to give it to me.
Zoom in.
Oh.
I know this game has zoom in, what do you call it?
I've played it before.
What do you mean watching your dad play the game when you're two years old
and kind of can't play that?
It doesn't kind of explain the game before.
What are you talking about?
Not more of them.
Not more of them?
Am I even supposed to do anything?
Not more of them.
Oh no, none of them.
This is a little too easy to play the normal.
What do you mean easy?
What?
I'm literally on legendary.
Look at the way I'm matrixing all the bullets.
I have no idea.
I have no idea what you're talking about.
I'm getting sniped by a jackal, go away.
Oh, my shield's down.
What are you doing?
Stop it.
I like that.
I can use some help over here.
We are.
Are I supposed to protect them?
I was in high school when the scene came out.
Oh, my God.
Oh, gee, son.
I'm hiding.
Literally using tree for cover.
I can't believe I'm actually having to play tactically.
How are you not dead?
I've literally sprayed a whole clip into you and then some.
What is being that noise?
I love the way they run away.
He's so scared.
Okay, close.
And he's still not done.
Right, I'm out to defend them.
Surely that's what the mission objective is.
I'm not wasting my time being here.
Surely the mission objective.
Uh-oh.
Another band are dropping in behind us.
They're trying to flank us.
They're dropping in behind us.
Master Chief from the hit video game series,
Fortnite Battle Fees.
The shit in my ears.
And I bulleted up my PC.
If you shoot at me one more freaking time,
I don't know what part is shooting at me, but I mean, I don't know.
That's it again.
Enough.
Enough of the rumbly loud tumbling.
Don't need to turn the game sound up down a bit.
It's getting a bit, you know.
That's it.
That'll teach them.
That's right.
That'll teach you a lesson.
Get out of here.
Don't come back.
Pretty cute until they come.
Right.
No more.
Bruh.
Come on.
One in three.
Yeah.
That'll scare them, literally.
They won't come back.
They won't be.
Oh, no.
We've got two at a time.
Grr.
No.
Oh, wait.
That's not.
Brr.
Are we done now? Or did I just move on to the next section of the map because...
I just can't really look.
I wish I could flip them.
Halo 2 is impossible.
We read you. Is that you, Fohammer?
Roger, Fire Team Charlie. Good to hear from you.
Hello.
Fohammer, we need transportation to the command shuttle.
Wait, wait, come on.
I'm on my way.
Look, more lifeboats.
Give me that warhog.
You're fast.
If those lifeboats...
There's no... If I had a sprint, ooh.
Fohammer, we need you to disengage your warthog.
The Master Chief and I are going to see if we can save some soldiers.
The Master Chief?
Roger Cortana.
The Master Chief.
Okay.
Now remember, when you drive cars in Halo,
you have to aim at your mouse.
You have to aim...
Ooh, it's your mouse.
Where am I going?
I assume this way.
It looks like we're going downhill.
Let's go gambling.
Aw dang it.
The Master Chief.
Okay, this looks like it, surely.
Jackal Snipers are appearing in Halo 2.
I'm driving.
Look, I didn't have to go and get lessons.
Oh my god.
If you wanna...
If you see...
Sorry.
If you meet it, then you know you have to go.
Oh my god, the driving is actually really nice.
Oh my god, where are we parking?
Nope, not this way.
Wait, why the...
Wait, what?
This literally looks like an underground car park.
Is this like a secret or something?
Why is there randomly this?
There better be a skull here if I'm going to explore in.
Nope, it's just...
I'm getting trolled.
Now parallel park!
We'll enter.
Wait!
Aw for fuck's sake.
Right, okay.
Oh, okay.
Ow, sorry.
You just stay on that wee rotating thing.
Right, let's go.
Okay, we cleared the gap.
Big drift!
I didn't realize it was around the corner.
Get him!
Aim bot!
Start shooting!
That's not a bridge.
Nope, do not.
Don't go for it.
Right, okay.
You stay there.
I'll go open the bridge somehow.
A little known secret about the construct is that they have huge parking lots.
Literally, I'm like, oh, this is perfect for my Warthog.
I don't even need like those mirrors that they're using.
Where am I supposed to go?
Looks at you with my gleeby eyes.
Ooh, let's not go on that.
Are you a password?
People, people, people, please open the bridge.
Right, bridge access over here, clearly.
Where the jackals are.
Yeah, okay.
If they put heavy or...
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Oh, okay, okay.
The lighten up, okay?
We're lighting it up, we're lighting it up.
We're lighting it up.
Follow the lights.
I know what to do.
Where's the door code?
Oh my god, it has a little beacon.
Look at my grind.
Such a whip.
Why did you AI lock onto me?
Scaring me.
don't you remember you're so good at this game that you already unlocked all
the skulls oh the skulls yeah they have to make more achievements because
mother is so yeah all this skull how could I forget about the skulls like
people obviously the you know I say people really it's just filthy casuals
they don't even play with the skulls on they don't even make it harder for
themselves so they just you can't even comprehend and thank you stash power for
reminding me of how good I am as you the skulls have a negative what do you mean
out get in get in what are you doing get in how do I get them in okay there we
go for people filthy casuals exactly like people just don't dedicate their
time to heal all the way that I do people understand he really said woman
driver I'm getting out why is it when I entered he's like everybody else no no
come on who's seen these schmoves he's talking with drift move he knows
literally he's already like all banged up he's already got whiplash from the
earlier bangs oh yeah reunion tour sorry you didn't see that you didn't see that
starting I'm getting cars sit no don't puke back there we fling don't puke hold
it together hold it together hold I don't know where we're going no but hold
it is it over here there's beacons flashing everywhere I don't know what
the oh shit no it's fine the windshield didn't crack that was just my back what's
the blue right I'm going this way okay okay we seem to have stumbled upon the
answer okay let's run him over oh sorry okay yeah you just keep shooting me I'll
I'm more efficient at Russian are we done that everything okay we'll move on
starting your driving to find out how else he's supposed to drive in Halo you
have to like use your little mouse sir like I have to like look around just
oh we're helping the Marines in the hill hi you guys okay I don't know what I
don't know what the handbrake is I don't know where the handbrake is are you
just coming with me okay but we're critic oh sorry sorry I just spanked the
back of the freaking Warthog I'm sorry right I assume you guys are fine have I
done what I needed to do I can't tell and I'm seeing green after that I
literally can't tell if we've done with this area or not I'm just gonna do a
little circle around it okay oh no no there's another covenant drop okay right
let's female, right spray and free
Wow! an Adler!
Stop it!
You stunk!
This is easy!
oh we did it we read you echo 419 we have survivors and need immediate
dust off as a sniper assault the hell
i spotted additional life phones in your area thank you you guys remember all of it
and another near the cliff edge hard to see from my altitude but it looks
right there are more survivors acknowledged we're on our way
press e it's just a terrible idea it might be i don't know we'll find out right no one
dispersed this time okay so where do we go now this reminds me of a recent video science
finding non-human structures in space in the first comment was well we will find aliens before gta 6
comes out didn't they didn't footage of that game get leaked and the dev team were so disappointed
what is this right wait i don't know
hold on wait no i knew that was there it's fine
it's fine i'm thank god these cars can take a hammer and that's all i'm saying
why what just took out my fucking shield son just took my shield spray and pray
like i'm mega early build and it looked bad
shiny do you think we could drive a little better no are you gonna be sick darling i'm can't i don't
know how to drive better it's so difficult because i have to control my mouse and i don't know where
i'm going and i can't like look around without dictating that the warhog is gonna go somewhere
else survivors detected marines i need to like get a good angle for them so the AI can just shoot
for me i can't see is there anyone where are they gonna come over no you know what you know what
you guys just stay in there i'm going to 360 no school come okay there we go
hi it's me master chief from the hit video game are you spain
okay okay i know what comes next i know what comes next okay so we'll be um
maybe not crash as much i'm scared from my like you're fine you're an armor we're all an armor
may might be a bit more upgraded than yours but it's still armored on the left
is there a cat i think one of it we gimme actually get forward
she was very needy this morning i had to because i woke up early to record the fully send
and gimme was so excited she was like oh my god you're weak and i'm like well steady on i don't
want to do
wait puma or what what what what what sorry i'm just trying to talk you through
oh sorry sorry i keep spanking the back of the damn thing can you get the jackal please
oh my god the ai actually kills no way this game was made like a billion years ago and the ai
actually kills this pure car i keep spanking the back of the buggy i didn't even mean it like
it just keeps happening
i'm trying to get rid of the car grand theft goal oh no no that's not grand theft goal
that's vehicular manslaughter that's what that is that's what that is okay we did
we're i can't even look up properly this is as far up i can look in the dang car
where is there something there
oh my god i'm so sorry i think i'm gonna have to like gimme
i think she's literally crying on the other side of the door unless it's the sound of it
oh and i'm gonna get the frenic there's no cat i'm literally gonna get the frenic
there's no cat outside my door i'm losing it i'm so sorry i'm actually losing it it's
the stress of um there's there's birds in the game making that noise oh my god it sounds like my
freaking cat right one more shirt now sorry i wasn't paying attention thank you ai for
taking over it right and the marines saved now i thought that was my cat tend to take those pills
no let's let's go i'm gonna save my life okay go oh my god so how does that the jackals like
destroy my shield
okay sorry but the ai is so
what does that mean we're ready for dustoff approach when ready ready for dustoff
dustoff right are they done that's that dialogue makes it sound like
like we're
we did it we finished the first mission
oh no that's for them sorry sorry sorry that's for them did i just kill him
all right am i supposed to get in that there's still one more okay okay let's go let's go sorry
sorry and it's like oh right um this looks like a dead end so i guess we'll go this way
and we just look for the beacons and that's where the blue beacons are okay let's not hit anything
before the reeflings throw up they already threw up because i was like two minutes late
i saw someone's like why don't you just use your loading screen how dare you one okay right we
came from there we're now here so is it down river reports that the covenant has located and
secured the pillar of autum's crash site so is there river down by the river
something new i assume it's this one
is it
huh did i do not just come from here
one how dare you two you're right how do you be right did i am i going mental if i don't just
been here you know if you're in there if you see a van down by the river
is on the wrong side we need to watch the mummy oh my god
i'm so excited for my weeb series i'm not even kidding oh my god that peacock literally sounds
like my cat is freaking me out i'm like oh baby girl i'm okay okay right let's go um but i'm so
excited for my make me a weeb series um i think it's the next week schedule every month we're
going to watch an anime series together can you get they need to kill them or can i just
i think i can just okay well save your um i think they took cover here
are they just gonna spray for me oh my god
ah
i'll do evasive maneuvers okay
i'm doing evasive maneuvers it's fine some more yeah yeah yeah give them some more give
them some more evasive maneuver i'll literally i'm keeping you alive you're welcome i'm keeping
you alive you're welcome oh dear lord moment hold on we're ready
it's too
this is a very powerful sniper oh oh i do enjoy that oh that's that is rather satisfying
come on
no they're up there if i hear that peacock sound one more time i'm gonna perish
you should search the interior of this oh that's so satisfying
okay we're to search the structure before we leave i think i just healed
by accident okay how'd i get in the structure it's fine giving me instructions to get
i see a stairwell okay i see it i see it i'm going up the stairs she got two headshots in a
row oh yeah it's an overpowered 50 caliber i like how it comes with a radio frequency as well
just i don't know what it means
rather rude of me i have to admit it's rather rude of me to do that but what i'm at thanks to the world
i'm exploring i'm exploring this looks important can i touch
well i'm not very good at exploring clearly
oh that's nice i like that do it again
oh i missed oh i missed
why can i only snipe his arm when he does that
come on ei actually get brief
come on will someone blow me oh my god that's so satisfying i love this
others
the music just coming on it nowhere right i don't know what i'm supposed to explore inside the structure though
oh but that would have been so cool if i had hold on you embarrass me don't do that again
be mindful of the limited ammo on the sniper oh whoa this looks like where we're supposed to go
i'm sorry i'm sorry i didn't mean that i was a mistake i am so sorry
i am so sorry
i am he was clearly moving to me within a threatening manner i plead innocent oh my goodness almost
went off that i'm not even kidding was that what i was supposed to do is this just like a mirror
that's the same on the side too i can't believe i just killed that man in cold blood
okay one marine retreat what's the friendly fire counting get no
can't prove it i found captain keys he's being held on a covenant cruiser the truth did we do it
clearly a spy exactly before we abandon the autumn right no more
i can't believe she does see us no you're a marine like me
right what am i supposed to do
get back to the warthog and then we'll figure out what we're supposed to do oh yeah
hey yeah you leave my warthog there's our ride get a board and let's get out of here okay
actually yeah why did they put in the mapping thingy like that but like never bother with any
details when i have to get on the ship the whole ship starts shaking press e to enter the
we did it we first mission complete oh i have no idea how many missions there are
on a rescue mission but we did it
she got my leg i'm so sorry it was a misty it was a misfire
what's higher the death counter the friendly fire gets stop we're gonna absolutely roast it alive
today but we did it captured captain keys and are holding him aboard one of their cruisers
the truth and that was the tutorial mission the ship is currently holding position approximately
three hundred years above the other end of this plateau that i'm a bit believe
a lot of we get inside the ship if it's in the air the core is just me a rifle not a wing
there's a gravity lift that varies troops and supplies between the ship and the surface
that's our oh my sniper still i should be able to lock on to the tracking thanks for joining captain
keys neural implant we're just chilling on meal i don't know what i'm doing i'm just here for a good 10
paying us by the hour stick to the higher ground to the right we should be able to
recon the covenant position without being spotted i've detected covenant stationary
guns near the next pass i recommend using your sniper rifle to take out the gunners while i call
for marina support there's no one on it get ready to move in to support us sergeant the master
chief is going to covertly take out as many of the covenant as he can don't open fire until you
hear the enemy return fire on us that should let us keep the element of surprise
uh cortana saying don't fire yet um oops
thank you the booty lord for the 10 gifted memberships and congrats to those who caught it
with your face uh i'm sorry but that's so comedic cortana being like don't shoot until they attack you
how is that how is this the element of surprise i'm literally going
like what how there's i just got an achievement this is cannon fodder 200
uh excuse me xbox
let who have it i killed everyone
to the one that was hiding behind the freaking rock let them have it
it
i like how the poor bruns are like so scared nice shot you congrats to the good things
cortana said the one with the red shirt bang he's my son oh my god i know that reference it's a meme
literally oh don't open fire you give it look you put a gun in my hand call me a marine and
you're surprised i've got a zero trigger discipline come on come on you can't eat
sorry but i'm victim blaming right now
we did it i think i killed literally everyone there's no we
what the fuck is that i can't even see what i'm shitting at
you hold on let me really right you go you go you go you go you go i love the sniper what the
heck it's such a good gun that's the noise i always remember the from the we aliens i always remember
oh it's anti-fricking pixel perfect oh
oh wow it put me like straight back okay it's fine it's fine it's fine
i'm trying to get a sniper spot stop it
oh my gosh i know the ledge a ledge in dairy difficulty see oh my god i'm playing
legendary difficulty
thank you thank you i thought about myself you literally saw my brain connecting the dots there
i miss i miss
10 out of 10 jokes how is it like skydiving without a parachute i keep making whoopsie whoopsies okay
is there anything else coming around the corner should we be going around the corner reaching you
right no more fallen off the ledge seriously we're getting outrageous now
outrageous behavior that's pappa l
it was our leg what i didn't get that i'll give you a bit of but i don't get it i'll give you a
or is that worse because i gave up it when i was in court on the fire team charlie
move up on the left you should be able to flank the enemy i can't even see
fuck it we hit fire and fuck it we both
oh please stop falling i don't know where i am i don't know where i am
oh my god i can't believe that i actually helped in this game
you have all these games all right sorry there's something from that you know what you go you go
i don't i don't even know what i'm shooting at i'm just shooting at it in general oh i miss
clearly that that's what we're shooting at okay nope i missed
okay we got them are we gonna we're gonna drop we're gonna drop
she might need herself i don't even know where the button for needs are so i'm i'm gonna keep it
that way the less i know the better thank you
oh my god i'm sorry i actually have to admit the sniper's really satisfying to play with
is there someone over there
something we're wearing go they're like
it's actually me that's wearing a skirt
soon we just wed yourself in between the canyon
oh my god two birds one stone two enemies one bullet i miss
if only there was someone with a sniper rifle
oh my god
oh you have to
oh i'm out no i love my little sniper rifle so roman soldiers are true
more enemy enemy well i don't know how to get more can you come up
oh my god that purple is tantalizing i literally feel like a fly that goes and zaps itself on
those blue like zappy things i kid you not that is tantalizing that purple that comes over
that's gorgeous on my eyeballs my eyes are like give me more of that
uh
it's a very purple game i quite like it
purple bull activates me
did you like the tizium me more fun for
the comments were like cracking though actually i need to go like the comments they
were like no mommy's good for power i'm like down street
there's someone who's like i inquired and they're like if you take them do you lose what makes
you new and i'm like fuck yeah what are you guys aiming at one enemy what's going on
why is so many enemies alive to survive
my fault uh my fault oh no that sorry
i'm gonna just let them tell me what to shoot at it
checkpoint donovan did i get i picked up sniper ammo wait why are we moving here
i don't know why i'm just following them i don't know why we're doing this thing
i assume we're gonna teleport on that ship we're kind of a dead end
um what are those i don't know though
don't get cocky kid what was that
oh my god what that looks terrifying it's a hunter
mesmer's flame honestly sorry but anything that's unironically like
makes my eyes die late i'm like um thank you again the booty look out of it
speaking of my eyes not as getting sucked up
yeah thank you again the booty look for the gifted membership
okay we're on the enemy ship like i'm hacking in people people people people
and if i licked it would it would it fry the the
you think maybe nobody's holding me i will pick this door wrong door i will pick this door because
there's red
no give me that sword i can't get the sword
no
of course there's gonna be covenant on a covenant ship i don't know why they thought otherwise
but what we
done marine
i can't wait how fast can i do that
that's as fast as i can go
i sound like i sound like a mixer in the kitchen
i got a rapid fire tongue imagine that on the end of your tentacle you'd be absolutely like
fucking quaking in your chair your little gamer chair if i did that
oh yeah imagine the vibration sensation
i could never survive the rapid fire
okay it looks like this is where we're to go because they've opened up this path
i assume if you guys are following me okay okay how am i of halo ammo like from my main gun
sorry that made no sense that sentence didn't make any sense let me in
i don't know if i i think i'm going to be mailing at this rate i really don't want to
we can find a way to open this door halo ammo i'm so sorry stop don't the bull why are you
some ammo god this game is so beautiful sorry but the purple like colors in that are so nice
sorry i don't have any ammo
uh literally have no ammo fuck you
i like how you just stop right i'm gonna need your needs give me the give me the gun
fuck you that's the lock door down there the marines are waiting on the other side
okay calls to open it must be somewhere stop it
okay stop it i don't have the ammo for this i literally have 14
i don't know i don't know i'm just million fuck it i'm just million i'm sorry i ain't
gonna ammo please forgive me there's nothing i can do wait what
wait i'm supposed to is that telling me where to open the door can you pick up any
new weapons i don't want to lose oh that's literally the can i drop that no okay i don't
trust that i'm not dropping down i'll just i'll just go for it i'm going for it the aim is real
stop it's so pure reverse it's literally so pure this i i maybe should have watched someone
play it before i just went for it because this is this is rough i'm sorry to anyone who is like
i can't wait to watch like a really fun playthrough of combat evolved and it's literally me like uh
my key uh i can't even use controller because i've messed up this is the best i can do people people
thank goodness i'm on legendary mode i'm conserving my ammo i promise
i'm conserving it should i just say melee only oh i did pick up thingy
okay we picked up ammo we picked up ammo but honestly it seems like melee is the way it go like
bonk like bonk bonk bonk like oh
i take it back
i don't i've never what i didn't even have what was that a grenade an enemy made
what was that she got that halo ammo star no don't make that thing that's so embarrassed and like
chat i play a game and you're just like completely moved even though the terminology is like
that's why i wait what wait i can't see anything press four and you can see what you need
you're a little flashlight
three halo deaths can't confirm it i will go back and cut it out of the board so i don't think i won't
oh sorry did i just kill my own guy a little bit maybe like i was an honest mistake
okay
i love the music star so
boom boom boom boom i think it's a lot of explosions
uh i'm looking i'm looking i don't know what i'm doing i'm doing but i'm going i'm going okay this
is a dead end i don't know okay maybe i'll help them a little bit okay just a little
oh there's a door i see it there's a door we're going for it
wait there's no indication if a grenade gets dropped hey there's no indication
no am i supposed to use my ears
am i supposed to have like the reaction
friendly fire will not be tolerated it was one bullet i'd stop
what's going on is it those ones is that a tape a grunt
oh i'm having a time right now
hold on
oh my goodness
yes eyes and people oh no
oh
i literally can't even see half the dying enemy
that's where we came from right no more getting killed okay
damn make myself clear no more grenade
no more i can't handle it anymore
the fun grunt
how did i get up there
this is locked
this red port right i'm going to go up that stairwell that was like over here
i'll wake up he's here
more specifically little grenade boys called kamikaze the ground
wait a moment will you access the covenant battle net and locate an override code to open a door
hold on let me read it bro
they're hurry corsado
you can't open the whole thing
oh working on it
i'd like to see more from the 28,000th modulating encryption key
uh
nothing i don't know i'm supposed to go
no fun grant in combat evolved
that's just naive
oh wait that's overcharge
hold on i remember now
okay what am i to do
oh
oh these guys are kind of scary
and their backs are kind of hairy
okay now wait no i still can't go it look it goes right as soon as you come out
combat evolved ar
what's that
oh let me guess i'm going to be all of my own some lonesome on the side of the door
not maybe not
wait no one dropped grenades
our grenades are my biggest enemy right now
i don't know how i managed to successfully
uh the bluetooth device has uh successfully perished like eight times in a row please give me a chance
i will have to say did i not just see an enemy
i did okay i will have to say the seamless ability to go from like dead to instantly load to your last
instance really digging out honestly
oh my god that's so sorry they're so reefland coded did anyone see that yeah i saw it mommy saw
it you did great darlin keep it up keep shooting you stay alive and you keep me alive those are
your two objectives look what i do with this i don't know we're destroying that that's what i'm
talking about what death you never dead exactly the marine dialogue is awesome
there is a lot going on
what the
you know actually controversial take for a game that was made like a billion years ago
this doesn't look that bad like i'm sorry i'm i think it looks good maybe i'm going crazy but
but or oversimplifying it but it's fine to me
okay new checkpoint game
it sure does how's that controversial i don't know like because i know the whole point of like
they kind of remastered it with a alternative as i broke my game like they remastered it to
look like all fancy and schmancy but the reality is i mean this doesn't look that bad for when it
came out and stuff i think it's done really well for itself the halo dev team should be happy it
aged very well yes i am inclined to agree you know what you know what see you you're back
okay where am i going i'm just letting it take me wherever the heck it's taking me i have no
idea i'm just going for it there's a lot oh there's reloading stuff there hold on i think i've
figured out if there's dead marines it means you can like heal up and yeah okay and get tons of supplies
got it i'm in danger the xbox og controller though i literally couldn't eat nothing
oh my god we're doing it we're doing it
i don't know how long this campaign is um i feel like because i'm just so good at the game we're
actually getting through it really quicker than normal we're in the command center blow this
thing up right now selfish oh wait okay maybe not yet maybe not yet no self-destruct 2001
you know for game god this is an actual maze
blow it up what about the keys uh
oh oh i thought that was the blue yuppie one
i thought i was about to blow up because i tried to melee the blue yuppie one
right if they're putting enemies in this corridor surely i'm going the right way
surely don't call me sure this is a maze this map i have to admit this is an all right that's a
red door that door's not red so we must be in the brig these look like holding cells there are
probably multiple detention stations the captain must be in one of them we need to keep looking for
you mean that one right there that that guy right there this one or what can i release them at least
yeah wait it it literally just gave me the prompt oh right okay sorry sorry sorry hi
you know the captain you did oh no we were too late for the rescue mission captain
captain right captain's not here what the heck he's just asleep okay right we can't go through
the red doors is there like a clunk in this room oh captain
oh i heard that okay okay oh no why can they jump
i'm scared i'm scared oh get away from me die
hi
okay am i safe where are my grunts you know what open that door again ah okay coming here with
reckless would you know better than this thanks
it gives you a spanking but then thanks yeah load your weapons let's be ready to move
that's the battle eats the ones with the energy swords won't eat you up
that's that's our jump wait we're getting shot in the cutscene by the jackal at the door
we're literally being shot at in the cutscene
according to the data in their networks the ring has some kind of deep religious
that's right oh did he just die did i just see him die next time
one with vast unimaginable power
oh
oh my god that perg run he's not being dismissed from the meeting yet so we can't engage in the
fight that's bad news if halo is a weapon and the covenant game controller i'm a professional
even the captain's getting so uh i have a new mission for you you need to beat the
covenants to halo's control if there's gonna be any left you have the point
if there's gonna be any left we should head back to the shuttle bay and call for
did he even read just look at all the blood that came out of um
brah he just not feel good he's a blood transfusion like right now and a good stake on top
oh my gosh that was hilarious i don't know if that's common or not but
that's certainly happened right what we're doing right we're taking them out of here okay so now
i need to backtrack through this massive maze
we are back tracking with the captain out we're safe through the way through the way
they really should have put songs in it folks off down to that's okay
it's really uncommon is it okay hi oh hi oh hi
third time's a charm i would just i would just need some time this morning what what does that mean
one goes thank you bro the legend for this it i can't believe he dripped me so much
john omni is a series that holds a special place in my heart and there is no better way to spend
oh my god happy birthday happy birthday to you happy birthday
thank you john omni i'm so sorry about the terrible gameplay
stop the growling is terrifying me stop it
the best you can do
the growling is actually scary
made it okay we're good we're good spell check wait i know i was like uh i was having a show but
thank you to him for the legend i've been engaged by covenant air patrols and i'm having a tough time
shaking them you'll be better off finding your own shaking them hit no vtuber in just as
funny i don't remember the
what we need to hold here until she can move in
oh man we're trapped in here we're screwed we're screwed man stowed up belly aching soldier
remember you're a letter for tana if you and the chief can get us into one of those covenant
dropships i can fly us out of here yes captain there's a covenant dropship still
i don't know i don't know if i can beat that one i don't know if i can be that one it's gonna be
honest all right who am i shooting at right what to do we're to get out of here right let's get
out let's get out of here i don't know where we're going but let's go literally band management
what was that john be allure looks really after the hit video game series fortnite
vtuber agency i don't know i don't know something like that
hold on what i do
i press eon stuff but it doesn't do up oh okay i keep getting jumpscared tell me that's not real
let's get on board the non-legendary band management honestly i'm having a word after the stream
bailout hmm i think not i think not give me a minute to interface with the ship's controls
uh no need i'll take this bird out well actually i hit eon the thing and it takes like a whole thing
to come up hang on
nice one sir time for a little payback
nice one sir
legendary melee user exactly thank you
yeah when i looked up this game it's like the campaign takes 10 hours and i'm like
i love these next two levels are they the best ones the island has multiple structures and
installations we're back on the island oh we're approaching the lz it's gonna be hot yeah this is
definitely a hot landing if they're already on the beach
the best mission time is this the best mission stop is it i'm excited
okay best mission time let's see what it's all about oh no that's friendly oh sorry sorry sorry
sorry mate i was just i was just cross fire
oh
do the jackals shield color mean anything maybe their shield is breaking i think i think it's
their shield is breaking the next two levels is what people think when you say hello okay
i need to sleep good night rest well
we deliver oh yeah i deliver too in pregnancy ishomar no we're doing c-section oh we're holding
time what time is there an enemy in the dip monster tree hi oh no i need to drive again
reef flanks did you take your anisek miss tablets it makes your mouth really dry
that will show us the location of halos control center oh oh check us out
we're oh my god we're doing a beach drive together this is so romantical
yeah oh sorry take your make sure your anisek miss tablets have been taken i've got plenty to
go around i'll take them to the if you don't actually need anisek miss tablets i'll tell you
the t basically the long and short of it is you take them and they make your mouth so dry
so you don't really before you're you're cute
oh that didn't work oh well i almost fell off there so let's not do that
can you shoot hold on what's going on here
there's a secret here oh did i just find a secret
huh oh that wasn't a secret oh i got really excited thinking i found a secret it's just a
hole in the cave it's just a hole in a cave oh i'm just so excited
but what am i doing here ledges is almost dangerous anyway seems like we're doing something
don't do that i hate when the game does that
freaking hell this is the area let's keep going inside
i don't know literally no one said this game was like jump steer oriented
no ammo
oh my god please leave me alone i'm scared
ah no i didn't mean to press apps sorry they've locked the doors and we don't have enough fire
power to get through them
what now go ahead keep the pistol maybe i found the control center
negative captain the covenant have impeded our progress we can't proceed unless we can disable
this installation security system oh faithful he'll all gone into stop i always don't miss
him but i didn't mean to explain that way but my words get stuck in my brain can't access words
and then i can't just go into the facility and find halos control center okay we're to
force our way into the facility we have to get to the center before the i'm good at forcing my way
into things aren't i really sure he he echo 419 to ground teams i'll stay on oh wait sorry
uh right we're gonna go down this hill i guess everybody's top side because they put loads of
enemies down here yeah
what can i go underneath no there's nothing i need to find the security override to get this door
open i'm still sort of from last time oh extra hill wait so am i in the right place i'm out to go back
am i going crazy
i'm not was that in the right place i just need gold
no what's happening did i move to the next place got a walk around the beach okay
that's going to romantic beach raid
oh
yeah you do the cover fire i need ammo thank goodness i feel so bad but every time there's
dead grunts i'm like uh a reload station exactly what i need
okay let's go around again
i don't think we need that where was there just seems like they're spawned here
oh this looks more like it
yeah yeah yeah i can do that right we'll keep her going
egg big green brood so good oh my god this is like a big beach tour i love it
this is my private wait what
wait go back you missed the place is this where we spawned
i think i've just done a big circle around the island it's all a start yeah i was like
wait i'm not right i need to go back so i need to go up where those
lake the beach mission inhaled that everyone messes up
right the warthog can't go there no get out get out of my way
got it
i'm walking i'm walking i'm enjoying the nature enjoying the views i am glad i have
oh no only i'm like the bonky you know i bonk me
oh that kind of hurt though
a stoppan wait hold on is something behind me as well
you're cheating only amelie to bonk
ow hold on i need to repair my shield warthog can't go anywhere you just have to shim in
why are you playing on those it's a shitty graphics it's it's um ancient graphic
you know they're a lot less terrifying when i have my a ai helping me
uh what's the grenade button g for grenade f
fuck you okay okay okay let's try that again
in my defense he literally came flying at me okay there we go
oh i was like g for grenade no f for fuck you instead
that was scary though he ran at me did you see it are they fighting each other
those eardrums shattering i'm so sorry should i turn down my microphone i can turn it down
uh i'm gonna run around more really quick
wait until woody i see on earth stop
a few enemies will run at you if you stick a money kamikaze style
they really said for the covenant huh
when you're not screaming you're actually just quiet oh no
No!
Streaming for two months still hasn't figured out
audio issues, real and true, and literally me.
Right, did you guys just spawn in here, or?
Gotta go back to your old Yeller.
Oh, trust me.
Okay.
Ah!
Stop, I can hear them.
Oh my God, they're like shuffling about.
You little freaks, leave me alone.
Fuck you.
Oh my God, stop!
Die already!
Eh, eh?
Okay, I have one of them.
How is it not dead?
Okay.
It doesn't seem to really register them in the room,
but yeah, so I'll take that as a good thing.
Okay, okay, we're good, we're good.
So anyway, I thought it was blasted.
Okay, I got a checkpoint for destroying those guys.
No more jump scares around the corner with enemies, though.
I didn't, like, that's twice I've been jump scared
in this game, twice!
She doesn't know, what do I not know?
You need to hit their back.
Oh.
Use the hollow panel to shut down the security system.
Uh, careful, we're gonna get flashbanged.
Good.
That should open the door that leads into the main shaft.
Uh.
Uh, what am I to do?
I'm not gonna go the wrong way, be honest.
Okay, it's fine, you can be honest with me.
Mummy needs no help finding the main shaft.
On the main shaft.
Main shaft, Minecraft, yeah, yeah.
Mayday, mayday, drop ship Bravo 22, checking enemy fire.
Repeat, we are under heavy fire,
and we're moving out.
So, I'm getting allies.
I better get allies.
On the hunt, we're on our way.
I need help, and I need, stop it!
Ah!
No, no, no!
Please, please, I don't have the ammo for this.
Get me out of here, get me out of here.
Oh!
Ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho.
I don't have the ammo for this.
Well!
I don't have the ammo, leave me alone.
Uh, don't have teammates, leave me alone.
Chief, Bravo 22 was bringing us out of heavy weapons.
After I saw we were up against the creatures,
I thought you could be here.
I don't get in there.
Let's move down the beach.
Am I going crazy?
Should I not come up here by walking down a frikin' side path?
Where did I come from?
What do I do?
I'm so turned around.
I turn her voice up and then she's like, Stop!
Don't turn me up.
I'm not.
I'm literally.
I don't have munition.
Can I just, can I just ignore?
I'm ignoring.
I'm not real.
I'm actually just a figment of your imagination.
Please!
Oh!
Ray, I'm away.
I'm away.
I don't need to do this fight.
I don't need to do the fight.
I need my reclings either at the bottom of this hill waiting for me.
Because you guys are in the war, Hulk.
There you are.
AI's locked.
Okay, now we're done.
I don't know.
We've taken down the security set and so we're going back to that place we were at.
I'm going to jump out and see if there's any more ammo.
Don't mind me.
I can flip this?
Oh!
That's rather impressive strength, I have to admit.
I did it on my own.
Wasn't there a rocket launcher?
I'm just a Master Chief with a rocket launcher.
Oh my god, yes!
Run him over.
Out.
Oh my god, he's Spanish.
Can I?
Oh, I did not just do that.
I might have.
You know what, fuck it.
You guys just stay out here and watch my back from out here, okay?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You guys just snipe and stuff.
I'm just going to leave you to do it.
You don't want the launcher?
Have you not seen my issues with grenades recently?
I am already in enough trouble trying to survive the game alone.
And you want me to mix in RPGs with that?
With my aim and my panic?
There'll be an enemy around the corner and I'll literally fire at them and perish myself.
I've got the flu.
Oh no, you won't feel good.
You need chicken soup!
I make chicken soups.
I'll show you my technique.
Right, what do I need now?
Cutscene time!
Okay, so there's supposed to be a light path.
I can tell by the way they were doing that.
Now what?
You're the enemies.
Do you think...
Why are they giving me such big enemies on my own?
I'm at...
Stop, Reflins.
Can money stream snipe me?
I'm not being funny.
My game, I'm scared!
Why does it say I'm getting...
Anyway, I start playing.
I'm gonna have to pick up one of the alien weapons.
I'm not caught out for this, okay?
I'm scared gamer.
I'm terrified.
Okay, that was actually a really good snipe out.
Nowhere though.
It says there's someone there.
Where?
I'm getting trolled by things and whispering right where I'm supposed to go.
Am I even supposed to be up here?
3, 4, 3 ghillie spark is gonna be fun, okay?
I'm gonna stop.
They were kissing on the bridge and I just killed them.
Checkpoint done.
So I'm hazing the right way.
Reflins!
Back on stream.
I don't know.
Stop!
Oh my god, I hate these big guys.
They're scaring me.
How am I supposed to shoot their back?
Stop it, not now.
Literally.
Okay, okay, uh-huh.
Right, that's a bit much.
Wouldn't be nice to me.
I made it so much worse.
Stop!
Stop doing this!
Stop it, you did it twice in a row.
You literally did it twice in a row.
I don't know what-
What was the logic?
I don't know what the logic was.
I just kept throwing them.
I went deaf.
You scared me?
I scared me!
Go-
So they don't go weird in kamikaze when I'm halfway across the map.
No, go away.
Leave me alone.
You're actually scaring me.
Right, good.
The logic is to approach them menacingly.
No, I'm doing it from halfway across the map.
Get sniped.
Ow, he sniped me.
Oh my god, right.
No, I shouldn't have learned what the fricking need button is.
Now I'm doing it to myself.
Literally.
Should not have learned what the need button is.
I honestly shouldn't have.
Just avoid them.
What do you mean avoid them?
They're big.
They're massive.
They're humongous.
What?
Avoid them.
They're like, how tall?
Isn't Big John supposed to be like a billion feet tall as well?
And they're still taller than me?
Okay, not to brag or anything, but I have a hundred and eleven billets and one need.
So it says one, one, one, one, one.
Can you get inside?
He didn't say what.
They're closing in too fast.
Negative.
Chief, you can come down to the front.
We'll keep them busy as long as we can.
Give him a hell, Marine.
You'll be in a tight spot if we don't get out of here before additional reinforcements.
Oh, tight spot, Sam.
Let's find that map.
Okay, I don't want to use too much ammo.
What did he say?
I do like the grunts being weaker.
Like, it makes me feel more confident when I'm going against enemies.
He panicked into me.
What?
Wait, what?
I'm getting a bit confuzzled, right?
I've just came here.
What he says they're four meters tall?
I'm like a meter six.
Rough.
I heard that.
I guess it's still, wait.
Wait, hold on.
Let me interact with this first.
Hold on.
Okay, checkpoint done.
Yep, let me just...
Oh, no, am I going to get shot at in the closet?
Okay, I despawned them.
Feels good.
What the fuck is that meter?
Master Chief is six foot ten.
I can't even...
It's not even why it's how.
How is he six foot tall?
The captain wants out of contact, Cortana.
His ship may be out of range or having equipment problems.
Alright, what do I do?
Let me know when you re-establish contact.
And then tell him that the Master Chief and I
are at the location of the control center.
The Master Chief and I?
I can't get over that sentence, Doctor.
I assume they dropped the ball.
Affirmative. Fall hammer out.
I've apparently...
Hold on.
What am I...
What am I doing?
Am I done? Can I come out?
Now, this is absolutely...
Wait, what?
Oh, god.
I get lost inside an enemy freaking...
command post.
Well, Master Chief is his rank.
Oh, it's like saying the captain.
Oh, the guard or...
Oh, this or that.
Oh, my god.
Sorry, I'm so turned around right now.
I don't even know how to get up.
Oh, my god, the music's so intense
and I'm literally just straight up stuck.
There's nothing intense about this.
I'm just trying to...
try to backtrack successfully
because I'm too dumb to figure out.
Literally, why is the guitar doing a solo?
I can't even get out.
I'm so lost.
This place is, like, unending as well,
which doesn't help.
I'm just go...
I'm just pressing W.
I think it's this way.
I came, I don't know.
Oh, my god, no.
Why is it taking me down?
Did I come up?
I don't know.
Okay, I don't...
I don't know if I came this way or not.
Directionally challenged, honestly, though.
I've just done a 360.
Oh, my god, wait.
Right, I see a corridor.
Right, I've got this corridor.
No, this is taking me down.
I went up.
Wait, ooh, what are you?
Hicked up active camouflage?
Don't mind if I do.
Time to melee with this banger on, honestly.
Wait, where did I come from?
Oh, do I need to go up?
Hold on, hold on.
Where am I going?
Okay, go up.
Up is where I need to go.
Okay, that's good.
Progress, progress.
I'm just following what the gun says.
The gun's pointing here.
Okay, well, I tried.
Mm-hmm.
What?
I'm so sorry.
Right, I think it's this way,
because the enemy's one here.
Okay.
Okay, I think.
Okay, I got checkpoint.
Progress, progress.
Come on.
It's really gone if you stop.
The gun pointer isn't a navigator.
What is it for?
The arrow points to threshold,
not objective.
What's the threshold?
I thought the threshold was
where the living room becomes the kitchen.
And there's like a little bit of straw,
and then it's called the threshold.
Go away.
Right, I think I'm going to make it.
I don't know how, but I'm going to make it.
Okay.
What is it?
Okay, we're doing it.
We're going upstairs.
What?
Almost there.
Am I first throwing out names?
Like, is there any idea what they mean?
Literally, please talk to me.
Like, I'm just, I'm newly spawned on Earth,
and I'm just here for a good time.
I'm just going to keep going up.
That's literally the only thing I'm focusing on.
Let's go upwards, in an upwards motion.
Unless there's nothing else to do in the upwards motion,
then we will go retrace our steps to the next level.
Okay, there's enemy here.
That's a good sign.
This looks near.
Oh my goodness.
Can I have that?
No, I can.
Where did it go?
Red.
Red, I wanted it.
I wanted it, I wanted it.
He needs to give me what I want, okay?
Not until Halo 2.
Oh, and Halo 1, they didn't let you have it,
but they coded it in the game.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I see it.
What is that?
Where's my...
I may have killed my Warthog,
because we're the heck are my allies.
I don't know where my allies are, they're gone.
They're gone to Spain, they didn't like me.
What am I doing?
Thanks for the funny spree-
Funny!
This is the worst gameplay!
Literally!
Thank you, M&S, for the kind words and the super chat.
I kid you not, you're looking at this with rose-tinted glasses.
This is the worst gameplay in the world.
Literally, have a good rest, but oh my gosh,
have you got rose-tinted glasses on?
They didn't have time to finish the story.
Honeycomb!
This is peaky gameplay, are you kidding me?
I'm literally getting jump-scared in corridors,
because it's dark.
This isn't the worst gameplay, this is nostalgia and carnage.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I'll take your word for it,
but I'm freaking ridiculous with this.
For our same plane, Halo blind is a great gameplay.
Halo ESL ranked win.
What's ESL ranked?
Mummy's strong points are her 10 points in the app,
and gaming's just the extra!
Honestly, thank god I don't know how to app.
I'd be over.
Is it over for me as a streamer?
Pretty much.
After this gameplay?
Yeah, diabolical.
I don't even know what breakdown is.
What video game's breakdown?
Break it down now.
Why is my tracking just died randomly?
Stop! I wasn't asleep!
Hold on, I'm re-calculating.
Red, don't...
Halo?
V-Trip...
V-Trip Studio?
Is it the game?
Is it the game, be honest?
I've been lagging out this whole time and have no idea
if I'm typically trying to not die in this game.
Okay, see this on the floor?
Little pointers to tell me where to go.
Gorgeous.
I'll have 20 more of them.
Your gameplay is always peak.
You don't have to be good, mama.
Just be yourself.
Aw, thank you, the Z-Lords.
Very kind of you, see?
Yeah, you like when I start screaming
because I accidentally kamikaze the big hunter
right in my muffy.
Yeah, you like that game.
Rub it all over you.
Oh my god, I'm loving this melee.
Sorry, they should make a melee game.
Where you're like, but not like a ninja type of melee.
Like, it's just, it's melee.
That's the gameplay.
It's melee and around everywhere.
Aw, he was asleep!
I wonder if the rings environment systems are malfunctioning.
Or if the designers wanted the installation
to have inclement weather.
Oh my god, I'm playing Assassin's Creed.
I'm literally playing Assassin's Creed right now.
I didn't even know they had stealth in this game.
What the heck?
They had stealth this entire time.
Oh!
Don't do that!
I didn't even know glass could break in 2001 games.
What the heck?
Bro.
This is so well coded.
What the heck?
I'm so impressed by the dev theme.
I'm sorry, I really am.
I'm just so, stop it.
I'm just so impressed with like everything they've done.
You saw an act of ammo?
Did that?
Aw, I guess I never put toot-toots together.
I mean, when did I ever, but...
Please don't go on that.
He's got the sword!
I'm sorry, please forgive.
Okay, I'm sorry, hold on a minute.
Reload!
Stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
All right, Dagnabbit, hold on.
Oh my god, please don't do that again.
Stop it, stop it.
No, we're not going on the gunner.
You did well to stay stealth as long as you did there.
Time out, time out, time out.
Literally everyone backed off of my master chief.
Does he have a pintas?
Or is that in sense for me to ask?
I don't know, does he have one?
Because isn't he like super strong and stuff?
Wouldn't he like split someone apart?
Would his pintas...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, not to be a weirdo,
but because he's super strong, right?
Wouldn't that make...
What?
Tracking, please!
My tracking keeps saying I'm asleep,
but I'm like literally looking point...
I don't know what's going on with my model, hold on.
Right, hold on, hold on, pause.
What's going on?
Why are you asleep?
I'm literally looking point blank.
Can you not see me, OBS?
Right, OBS can see me.
What about you, VTuber Studio?
What's going on with you?
Wake up.
It's the first of the month, VTuber Studio.
Don't put me to sleep again, you understand?
I'm looking point blank at this game.
What do you mean I'm asleep?
Stop it.
I'm looking point blank at the game.
Point blank.
Don't do that again.
Hold on, let me recalibrate,
but I don't know why I'm in trouble.
Considering we're playing on the old graphics,
I'm recalibrating.
Okay.
If it keeps lagging out like that,
and putting me to sleep when I'm asleep,
when I'm awake, it's getting a spanking.
It's like, where am I to go?
Inside the arena?
Okay.
I'm not sure where I'm supposed to go,
but we're learning.
Are you asleep playing?
Yeah, I was literally asleep the whole time.
I don't know why it was acting like I'm asleep.
Wait, I can't sleep.
Nope, I'm too big.
Oh my god, I love the glass bracing.
Any glass?
Wow.
Whoa.
Secret?
No.
Just design.
Okay, sorry.
I thought that was a secret.
Gaming and yapping in her sleep while I'm one absolute legend.
I'm just letting her do it.
We're on a lift.
She started his Spartan career at 7,
and is 41 at the end of this game,
if I remember.
Legendary while asleep, exactly.
I think the process of becoming a Spartan rex
is reproductive system.
Oh my god.
He doesn't have any swimmers?
Oh no.
What happened to Reggie?
Where are my resticles?
What's the name of the captain again?
I forgot.
Whatever the name of the captain is,
when Master Chief wakes up on the other side,
Captain, where are my resticles?
That looks cool.
Why do they have to be yoink to turn them into a thing?
He's got a lot of people first, that's so cute.
You know what it feels like?
I'm playing whack-a-mole right now.
I'm really enjoying this.
This is so cute.
Boom, boom, boom, boom.
Boom.
Okay, give them a little spritz,
and then we boom up.
Because you're normally too hip.
Stop dodging!
We're there.
I'm loving it.
Thank you, Reverse.
I'm glad you're enjoying it.
It feels like I'm playing a really fun game of whack-a-mole.
Where's the heck are we?
Oh no, what are you shooting at?
What's with that?
Oh my god, it's a ray!
How did I deal with the Is there a rocket launcher?
Give me that right now.
Give me the rocket launcher because there is a ray.
There is a ray!
No!
You know what?
The hit and run is really fun when it's not against me.
Don't do that again.
What the heck?
A ghost just took me out.
Bruh.
That was a ghost that just sidelined me
whilst I was trying to deal with the freaking ray.
Bruh.
Right, that better not happen again.
Or someone's getting in trouble.
Oh my god, please.
Where's the ray?
Here he comes again.
He is coming in the corner.
Can I use this?
Oh no, I can't.
See you UV Bounce Prime.
Oh my god, the wraith is scaring me.
Wraiths are really scary
and
can it?
I only have tanks too?
Oh, I'm not sure.
I'm not sure.
I don't know if it's a good idea
to fucking walk near it
but I kinda need to be able to hit it.
And that wraith is really hammering them.
It's good to hammer me.
Fuck it, fuck it. If we die, fuck it, we both.
Eh?
It takes two to kill.
Okay, understood, understood, understood.
Two to kill.
Bueno amigos.
Buenos noches.
Dnde est la ugre?
Dnde est la biblioteca?
That's the best I got for Estangles.
Nice shot.
Oh yeah.
Master Chief.
No more wraiths, okay?
I'm getting scared.
I can handle jackals.
I can handle ghosts for wraiths.
Make me nervous.
Make me...
Okay, I guess.
Can you guys jump down?
Am I supposed to be in the warthog right now?
Spanish approval?
I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I heard bad noises, okay?
No!
No, I can't get in!
Oh my god.
Everyone climb aboard on the victory wagon.
Do you want on the other side?
Are you coming on the other side?
Oh my god.
I'm so...
If you die, you can just say you fell asleep.
Real.
Oh my god.
Tank mission.
Right, you guys need to reload a bit faster.
But otherwise...
I missed.
He did a backflip on us.
Oh, I missed.
Okay, hold on.
There's a wraith!
There's a wraith.
Can you reload?
Oh my god, please.
Can you guys deal with the jackal and the ghost whilst I deal with a literal wraith
that is aiming at us?
Sorry for being so stressed,
but you guys are the worst aimers I've ever seen.
Oh my god, I love the tank.
We're in the panther!
Hello, Lighter.
Today we are in the panther,
and we are going to annihilate the panther.
Yes.
As you can see,
the aliens kindly constructed
the corridors nice and big.
Let me in!
Why am I not allowed in?
I'm stuck.
Hold on, you guys.
Hello?
Knock knock, let me in!
Is that not where I'm supposed to go?
Touch on...
Sorry, my tracking is really having a hard time with this.
I think there's a frame rate in the fridge or something.
You need to open the door by hand.
Oh.
Oh!
No way!
Oh come on, don't be so silly.
Are you guys putting on the other side?
Or...
Bro, imagine getting out of a...
Are you coming or are you just going to stay there?
It's up to you.
You just stay there, we're fine.
Literally...
Imagine getting out of a big old tank.
Everyone getting off only two seconds later.
Ooh, those speed bumps for the tank.
The scorpions holding it together nicely.
Oh, buh buh buh buh!
Oh, I have like a secondary fire as well.
Okay.
Okay, that didn't work.
Hold on.
Let's do it!
Okay.
Oh my god, it can like...
It can't see?
Get on the...
Floor!
I can't floor it, we're in a tank!
Right, you guys need to start shooting because what is going on?
We ain't going to make it if you guys are acting like this.
I need my shields to regen.
Okay, it's regening.
Oh.
Wait, we're not to go here.
Sorry!
Beep, beep, beep, beep!
We're not supposed to go here.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Okay, we're all in the tank.
Okay, okay.
Okay, now...
Oh my god, I can't see, bro.
Please.
Okay, stop, right.
Hold on, hold on.
See, because none of you jump off and open the freaking door,
we can't floor it.
Do you understand me?
If one of yous were kind enough to actually open...
I can't floor it, you're not all in.
Right, there.
Okay, let's go.
Why are there six pedals, bro?
Me, honestly.
Technically, they can't use the doors
because of lore reasons.
They can't even go beep,
and then swipe out a pass key.
That was rather strange.
Oh my god, that perg run on his own.
Okay, let's make our way up here.
And annihilate the jackals on the way.
I can't destroy the ship.
Because that would be too easy.
Okay.
As if you dropped that into the wind.
I can't even be arsed with the
the ship firing at me if I can't
need damage to it.
Can you be...
Run versus a tank.
Oh no!
What does that mean?
Yeah, hombre.
I love doing what the...
voiceline.
Is that a ray?
It was!
Are we...
Are we to go in there?
Are we to just keep going?
I missed.
Is this just a dead end?
No.
Off of music.
Okay, I missed. Hold on.
Okay, I missed again.
Okay, if this is just a dead end...
Wait, it's not...
I can't actually miss him.
Okay, we're definitely to go inside
that little entrance way thing
that I saw.
I'm gonna just leave you guys out here.
You can come with me if you want.
You don't have to. I mean, I'd like you to.
But it's okay if you don't want to.
We're gonna do something in here.
I don't know what it is.
Hmm...
There's something up here.
It says red on my minimap.
Oh!
Whoa!
Just say you don't want to live,
because, bruv, why are you letting that happen to you?
What's this one?
It is.
Okay, we came in here.
Oh, sorry!
I'm sorry.
Whoa!
Wait, did I just drop the tank for no reason?
I think I did.
Where am I supposed to go?
There's nothing to do in there, right?
You were going the right way with the wraith.
Okay, everyone back in the tank.
Go back through the building and in the tank.
Mommy's a bit slow.
Okay, mommy's a bit slow.
Apparently it is behind the wraith, but I'm dumb.
Just the camel for fun, dude.
Right, okay, everyone back in the tank.
And you come.
And you come, reflins.
Make sure you take your motion sickness, okay?
All right, there you go.
Yep, good, good boy.
Oh, you're so good, aren't you?
He was stuck on it!
Okay, that wasn't men!
He was stuck on it.
He wasn't a real reflin anyway.
It's fine.
He wasn't a real reflin.
And, not being funny,
I reversed, so he walked into death.
Is it behind there?
Right, how was I supposed to see that?
That's it.
They're getting...
They're getting a strongly worded letter.
After a shenanigan like that,
reflin card revolt, literally fake reflin.
Oh, my God.
That's the second aim at that.
Ooh, really do not want to go flying off the road.
Can I?
Oh, my God!
How are we supposed to, like...
Ooh, careful!
Yeah, maybe don't go in front of the tank
when I'm the driver.
Do we want to start using our brains a little?
Yeah?
It's called not walking in front
of the moving tank, okay?
Especially while
strongy chief is the one who's driving it.
Little sausages.
Who's your daddy now?
Daddy.
Okay, let's go inside.
Whatever this is.
Okay.
Are you okay?
The music is bumping
in this game.
Ooh, I see a platform.
We're coming. We're saving you.
We're saving you.
Easy peasy.
I like how the grunts actually get scared.
When you kill, like, a bigger one,
the grunts get scared and they're like,
oh, let me still do that.
Get out of that.
Oh, my God, I almost got ran over by a freaking ghost again.
Go away.
Can I just go in this?
Oh, I can!
Eat lead, motherfuckers!
I feel like I should not.
Oh, my God, I have to judge the bullet distance
though.
Oh, no.
Oh, come on. I have like a one in three chance
of it hitting. Come on.
No way. Come on.
I have a one in three chance.
Oh, no!
Okay, there we go.
We did it.
I'm going to spray that one.
I don't know.
The accuracy is pretty rough.
I only know that from Conqueror Mayford.
I know.
Five missions in it.
She's just making the...
Well, excuse me.
Sorry, did I interrupt your listening session?
No, you can't kiss each other anymore
on the lips.
One.
Shhh.
They're going to sleep.
They're going to sleep
like this.
He's coming!
Roughly
going to sleep.
Shhh.
They don't know.
Soft lips.
Soft pants.
The interlocking mouth feeding.
Baby Birdie.
They got split lips,
but I don't think they're species kiss.
You just give that...
You woke up the babies!
No need to put them down.
The poor little grunts.
They didn't deserve this.
They could have...
They could have known peace
before their demise,
but no, no, no.
You had to go and ruin it.
Now they're all scared and worried
as they're getting perished
and exterminated.
Come on.
You could have been nice, but no.
And now I'm the bad guy.
That's right, make me
cry.
Where do I go?
Don't actually know
where I'm supposed to go.
Stop it.
See, now they're pleading for their literal life.
Oh my god, I love the arrows on the floor.
Please, give me more of that.
How come they didn't have that at the start?
Or maybe they were already there.
Oh, elevator time.
I'm on a lift.
Can you jump?
Oh, you can jump on the lift?
What the hell? Where are we going?
To the bloody command center?
I thought we were under
a ground.
Underground.
Right, what is in here?
A few fallen heroes.
But it means I can scavenge
off of them. Thanks mate, appreciate it.
Your life was not in vain
because I had you.
Bumped.
I'm chasing them down
like a horror movie.
Oh, that perk run.
Literally chasing them down
like a horror film.
I'm so sorry.
I'm like making them all prefer.
Thank you.
Joan Omni.
Stop.
By the way, I never said thank you.
Apparently
to go out already?
No.
Bunk.
I can't bunk these guys.
But I like the bunk mechanic.
Bunk.
I love this game.
Oh my god, I love this game.
Come here, Bunk.
No, I miss Bunk.
Bunk.
I guess it's because
I have such inhuman strength
that I'm like strong enough to bunk.
I was gone for 15 minutes
and got thanked by Momy.
You gave me a super chevrolet.
I forgot to thank you by name.
I've been really bad at doing that recently.
I don't know why.
I think it's just because I'm
getting used to going and just
like, oh, reefing.
Whoop.
I'm going to do that.
There's an arrow pointing here, though.
Errrrr.
Is there a gun that does that
in this game?
Or is this
going to be an assault rifle?
It's just kind of, it's an assault rifle.
Little light machine gun, maybe a heavy machine gun.
Bonk, bonk, bonk.
Ah!
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm baiting off more than I can chew.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I'm getting too excited to bonk.
The halo rifle is a stove.
Okay, okay, assault rifle, got it.
Let's just spray and pray.
Again, you know what I'm saying?
I have no idea, I'm gonna be honest.
I don't know what the mission objective is.
I'm just, ooh, arrow on floor.
Ooh, enemies that I've not dealt with yet.
I'm getting snake.
Well, if there's hunters on the other bridge,
let's hope I don't have to go on that bridge again.
Okay.
Ba da da da.
Something's tally-wacking me.
I'm just going for it.
You got to upload Cortana into the microwave.
What?
You got to upload Burkana into the frame.
Whoa!
You got to upload Cortana into the main frame.
Why the microwave?
Why did my brain even read that?
It doesn't even say waves at all.
I'm so sorry.
Absolutely butchered your advice.
Literally just trying to help me get through the game.
And how do I repair you?
Just, like, I'll be talking a little bit.
Oh, the baby's are asleep again.
Bonk.
That would be for your road gun.
Brain didn't, yeah.
Um, I never got much sleep
because I was doing so much of my work yesterday.
But I, oh my God, I did, like, big work,
which makes, like, obviously, my work a lot less.
Um, unironically, I'm doing, like,
the Avengers assembled and I'm getting the editors
to all communicate to one another,
so I don't have to delegate the Patreon edit.
And, oh, not again, not again!
Oh my God, there's no run, there's no run.
Oh my God, not again.
There's literally no run.
I really don't like these enemies.
I really don't like them.
Oh my God, stop, they're so big.
Oh, I really don't like it.
I really don't like it.
I really don't like the hunters.
They scare me.
I, like, I could, oh, right, you.
Oh no, no, let's go.
If I had a super weapon.
Oh my God, this is a bit dramatic.
This is a bit dramatic.
Oh, fuck it.
Okay, hold on, I need, like, any guns in there.
This is getting ridiculous.
Oh, for fuck's sake.
What am I to do?
I'm getting blasted right now.
Ah!
It burns!
Oh my God, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop.
You're all making me scared.
There's, like, so many enemies this map.
Is this it?
We're not at the end game.
There's no way we're at the end game.
I just feel like this map is, like, going for it.
Oh my God, maybe I shouldn't have woken up the baby.
Sorry, go back to sleep.
Cause I had rules, shall I bump into deep and I'll really care
about sticks and violins, I love music, fuck, I love the island.
Oh my God, maybe.
Oh, this, like, this is a really effective gun.
What the heck?
Sorry, I'm just following the arrows on the floor.
Imagine if the arrows aren't real.
I'm getting really tired.
I feel like we've been here before.
Wait, never going down.
Have I just done one big massive circle?
I mean, there's new enemies.
Hold on, I got itched my nose, hold on.
There's new, oh!
Don't do that!
The map is kind of looping, at least what I'm saying.
Right, okay, I'm glad I'm not going crazy,
cause I'm like, did I mess up?
Am I wasting everyone's time right now?
Imagine if I was wasting everyone's time.
That's like, terrible gameplay.
Oh!
Oh, the melee animation's different.
No, it's with my fist.
Bumper.
Where?
Hold on, hold on, I've got it.
Yep.
Okay.
This map is very, very turning me around.
Don't, don't, don't, don't!
We should come and hear one of those ghosts.
They're going to need the firepower.
Wait, I'm coming to hear one of those ghosts.
Rrrrr!
Where are we going?
I saw a race.
I'm not sticking around to find out
how to 1v1 a rape on a ghost, okay?
Or do I have to?
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, we have hope.
We have hope.
Hope is back.
Ooh!
I see it, I see it, I see it.
It's okay.
Oh my God.
What is that?
Sniper ammo?
Why is it giving me?
It's giving me a rocket launcher back.
Oh yeah!
Right, what is going for me?
Leafy Bams is going for me.
As if!
Right.
What am I to do?
Is that a staircase there?
I think it is.
I ain't got my Gleik's on, but it looks like a staircase.
Copium?
No, that is, that is, look.
There's a purple command thing there.
I ain't got my Gleik's on.
Up the pyramid, yes.
Oh jeez, you fucking scared me!
Oh my God!
Stop!
That ledged the scum.
I didn't even see the hunter,
I was so focused in on the wee grunt sleeping.
The fact that he got a scare from me,
and I got a scare from him.
I've got my heart rate monitor on right now.
Get off of it.
Needle.
Right, fisty cut.
Fight me like a man!
El mano, el mano.
Brov.
Brov, please stop moving.
Okay, thank you.
I got plasma grenades off of them.
Oh wait, no, we can't go this way.
Sorry!
Right, up the pyramid.
I do pity the grunt.
I pity the fools who pities the grunts.
They're adorable.
I think they're very cute, if I look them.
Bonk!
Poor little guys.
I do pity them for their patheticness.
Bonk!
Oh!
Eh!
Wait, what?
Wait!
Where am I?
Did my game bug out?
Why is this my last Lord's station?
Why is this my Lord's la-
Why is this my last Lord's la-
Last Lord's station?
Is that a joke?
Even though it's like save, loading, loading, loading, loading,
every time I go do something.
Oh my god!
Wait, how?
There's no way.
How?
I was at the end of the mission!
There's no way I wasn't, like, right at the end of that mission!
Wait, check your saved games?
It says assault on the c-
Defend the control room against wave after wave of covenants.
The grunt smacked you so hard it sent you back several saves.
Literally, what? I was like, was that not right at the end?
Last checkpoint?
Is this my only Hail Mary?
He returned to you before you killed the Marine randomly?
At least you're a reviewer.
Awww.
Nah.
What?
Enzy.
Fuck!
What mission am I on?
Bruhhhhhhh.
Moe, you bums.
Welcome to gaming in the 80s.
Bruhhhh, what?
This is literally, I'm not being funny.
We're playing the, the old, we're playing the new version,
so none of that piss should be happening.
I don't know why the games act in, like, it,
we actually are playing old school.
Cause, what?
The Covenant placed their tanks to defend the entrance to the tunnel.
I, will literally, I'm short right now.
Awww.
I don't know what to do.
Like, the only thing I can think is just bomb rush it at this point
and just pretend that we didn't lose all that progress randomly.
See, checkpoint done!
So, is my fail bugged now?
And if, if I die, it's gonna send me back there?
I really hope not.
I, I really hope not.
I'm just bomb rushing it, I'm sorry,
but we literally have done this.
We probably were what?
About five minutes from finishing the mission?
There is no reason that should have happened.
Absolutely no reason.
Yeah, fuck you.
I'm bomb rushing it, I'm bomb rushing it.
Bro, there, I have a horrible feeling my game file is bugged
and if I die, it's gonna send me back there every time now.
See, checkpoint done.
Does that mean save?
Or are checkpoints different?
Rolling Thunder, new location.
So...
Can you help me out here?
Frickin' 34th!
Three industries!
Not even for, waiting for the Marines to hop on.
They're not refling, so it's okay.
That's supposed to be the save.
Why they got remastered the game without fixing the bug?
I swear, I bet you'll be like,
oh, that's like a mega super rare bug
that no one ever experiences.
Obviously, I get it with my streamer luck.
If I can just literally ignore everything,
I'm just going for it.
I'll deal with the wraith.
It puts me on the bridge section.
The bugs are inevitable.
Like...
I do love shooting them.
I can't believe that.
Checkpoints kinda bugged is common.
Don't say such things to me, honestly.
My heart can't handle it right now.
I thought the Covenant had eliminated all the Marine forces in this area.
Yeah, away from the tank.
And they're all gonna jump.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
So...
What happens then?
The Covenant is jumping in behind us.
I like, I'm jumping out of the way and I don't even go after them.
You know, it's a first and not gonna be the last rate.
Okay, as long as it was like some super rare, like, amazing thing that no one ever gets,
but I end up getting it,
then I can't be that mad.
But I...
I'm probably gonna ignore everything.
Uh...
I'm trying to remember what we were going for.
I'm playing legendary,
so I'm able to avoid the bullets a lot better than you would.
So don't worry about it too much, but...
It's normal to be jealous.
Oh, no. It's normal. It's okay to be jealous.
Right, okay.
My checkpoints have fixed themselves.
That is progress.
So...
We can continue.
Oh my god, I have to do all of that again.
Don't do it.
Stop it.
I can see he's going nuts trying to get to me.
Oh!
I forgot about the one kissing in the corridor.
Leave me alone.
I've already done this part of the game.
Be gone, fellow beasts.
Right, if I take a left, what happens?
I don't know.
I don't know if this is wise to bum rush it
because I might die and then get even more annoyed.
Is it in the middle?
Where the heck is it?
This is one where it's in the middle
and you need to buckle a wall to get around it or something.
Bra, stop.
Why is it even here?
Why is there a push mechanic?
Oh, we went past it.
It's fine.
Leave me alone.
The checkpoints do get a little corky at night.
Just chilling.
Right, right.
We're already on the first part of the bridge.
Go across the bridge.
Go through the mechanic.
Sing.
Just bum rush it.
Any bum rushers?
Any bum rushers.
Yes, yes, yes.
Bye.
Leave me alone.
Right, okay.
Cross the bridge.
Give me ammo and stuff.
Right, that's fine.
I'll do it.
Right, and then...
And then what?
I don't know.
I forgot.
I'm just using...
I'm just doing...
I'm going to assume it's...
Nope, it's not at the symmetrical opposite side on the map.
Don't get excited.
Where the fuck is it?
Reflings are natural born bum rushers.
I'm a flume.
I don't think it's necessary to do how many enemies there are around.
It's something about the loading triggers.
You must have missed one of them,
and then it just absolutely forgot everything that I ever did.
Stay asleep.
Rock on my baby, on the tree top.
When the wind blows, the cradle will rock.
And when the cradle rocks, it'll swing in the wind.
Swingin' in the wind.
I'm swingin' in the wind.
Bum rum pum pum.
I didn't see him,
and he's actually pretty big.
De-spawn already!
De-spawn, everyone de-spawn.
Checkpoint done.
Yes, the top left checkpoint done.
Right okay, don't remember what was supposed to be.
I'll literally play an assassin's Creed right now in Halo
Those jackals can take your full shield in one hit. That's a bit of a problem
Stop stop I need this to recharge stop
I'm gonna far I'm gonna far I'm getting annoyed. Oh
Oh
My god, I'm actually gonna die. I'm actually gonna die
The shield mechanic want to come in or am I just in the rear? I'll like shield again
I'm actually going to die
We're going to break we're going across the other side of the bridge now
Need them no because they're gonna run into me and then I'll be even matter I
Just need to make sure I don't lose my shield that's when it becomes a problem
Is there no dead I need like a Marine's body to heal up
Okay, I'm just I'm gonna pretend I didn't even see him you're invisible. I'll let you believe that you're
Yeah chip damage before the shield went off again
Surely it's just perfectly on the other side of the map
I'm like lawn ammo as well
We're gonna die
I'm really needing a Marine body. I'm literally out. I don't have
The only other thing I have is a rocket launcher. You can't make it. Oh
And there's another one in the corridor
Buckle give me your gun
Country girls make do you need to pray well the plasma I don't even know what this one is
Oh
There's a fifty-fifty
Curse Halo is a fun game. What? Oh my god. Why did I just alert the AI to my position?
I don't know. I was just feeling corky like that
You drop the rocket launcher, I did
Ammo and there's no
Scavenged from stop in my way
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, I don't have time for this
Fucking get me up. What is this this one supposed to be? Oh
My god, oh my god, it's like what?
That was bizarre was that what I was supposed to do. I hope that was what it's locked
Whoa, what am I supposed to do?
We'll just fly down towards the pyramid. I can fly on the permit. Oh, sorry
I
Point unlocked, please I'm begging
Checkpoint checkpoint checkpoint. Oh wait up here Danny fly up to that next thing
Yeah, skip a little chunk of the level. Oh
There was like a little slope right there. Haha. Sorry
Oh
Okay, now we're at the top of the pyramid
The collision of a vehicle can kill you your own vehicle that you get off can make you perish
Wait, there's nothing here
What? I've been trolled
I like how the race is still all locked to me even though I'm up here
I just get trolled. There's a switch at the door, but warning there's a lot
There's a switch at the door at the door at the door
I like how the concept of doors having locks is like so lost on me
Because it's just not a thing in your game mechanics like all doors are unlocked
Okay, right I
Think it handles that all right all things considered
Yeah
I think thank you for the heads up
Okay, I guess everything
Oh, no wrong book
That's really
Covenant forces in the vicinity have been eliminated. I really don't want to die now. I don't want to replay this mission
This is a very big one is this the beach missions considered the best one right because this one
Is it blames me? Oh wait, is that how close I was to the end of the freaking mission control center
That's how close I was
She doesn't know about the witness we were
Next mission's best one
Pain for the one mission
That terminal try there
Thank You Cortana
Oh my god
Let's stay focused halo, how do we use it against the covenant? It's not the original voice actor
It's something else something much more important. What?
this ring
What is it give me a second to access
Yes, the forerunner built this place. Fuck. It's a forerunner. What the fuck is a kilometer?
No, that can't be
Hydration check. Covenant fools. They must have known there must have been signs
Slow down. You're losing me the Covenant
Cortana
Something buried the captain. We've got to stop the captain keys. What are weapons cash?
He's looking for it's not really we can't let him get inside. I don't
There's no time get out of here find keys stop him before it's too late. Okay, geez Cortana, geez
Hey, you know you could like just say like a few sentences while I walk out
You know just to explain the situation because games are always like there's no time
RGB Cortana
Did they say it was an action game? It's a horror game
Will there be aliens who run in from me?
I'll show you. I bet you are well enough alone. It's called this mission
You're gonna hate it. Have fun
We're in the welcome to the jungle where we've got guns and games
You guys what we're having a hurricane
Where did they come from did a plant just pick them up is he plants enemies?
My god, I like the rainforest
I'm a sucker for rainforest
Good luck. Come on. We you're about to ink
Am I supposed to go up where he was
I'm a wee bit turned around in this map after be honest, but oh no, you can claim the tree. Okay, well, I see the enemy over there
Fucking hero radio
Oh
Wait, that's where I was sorry sorry slow very slow right now my brain's not quite here
She's gonna get so lost on this level which I already just got myself spun around
Right, I assume across the bridge because there's a light there there. Yeah, okay. I'm not gonna grunt against that yet
And
The ambience is getting a bit creepy
Now we're holding up
There's no way you're running away in fear, but when I show up you're like I'm not hold on a minute
Oh, I literally spun around
Oh, I'll that took fall damage. I can even get on the thing in time
Oh, yeah
Oh captain, you're not supposed to do something. I don't know
Bonk
Okay, I think we're bonking
You're like weird alien radios like nothing stuff. Well, there's a green door. Okay, assume that
Yes, you you're first
Oh
Hi
You have a shotgun in this level
No, I don't you have a shotgun in this level. You're gonna need it so gooey. We'll be gooey
Thank you the beauty Lord
I
Give me a needler
But no shawty hello
The government counts
Like the monsters are everywhere. I did that's what I did
Thank you
Well, they like voiceless intimate the wazoo
Get it
They won't get me. Oh god. Oh god. I don't want to be like oh, he's
Danny a pillow mose misery
I'm sorry
Sorry bro, I think it may be better that way because something's got you all freaked out
What is this place is on fire the world's on fire. How about yours? Oh, no, is that my world on fire my world's on fire. How about yours?
Next brand of greenery
People people
Okay, nothing works when I'm
Look around
Every now and then I get to see
You
And honey, it's so
Um green door, okay
It's the way I like in
What does this mean what is that melody? Oh, I've got healing. Oh, okay
I
Okay
Oh my god
So enter your that looks like a pin card machine in the uk
The red is to cancel the the yellow is to take away one digit you put in wrong and green is to confirm
That's literally a pin pad in
Oh my god. No, you didn't make it. Let me just pop you down right there
Well, I think he's definitely ragdoll and his eyes are open
We shake our head he didn't make it
Leeroy
Open a record of you
Oh my god, we have the dashcam footage
Okay, let the other person incriminate themselves so they can also get done for telling the wrong information to the police
Why do we always have to listen to this old stuff serge?
Watch your mouth son. Oh a hydration check is your history. It should remind you grunts. We're fighting to protect
Hey, if the governor want to wipe out this particular part of my history, that's fine by me
Yeah, better it than us. You ask real nice next time you see him
Sergeant johnson. I'm still gonna be happy to
Alfie looks clear. I'm bringing us down
apple juice cans for hydration right? Oh, pineapple juice. Go go go. I think so
Fast forward
Play play
Stay close Jenkins
Left foot right foot left foot right foot foot foot foot foot foot foot foot
Mendoza move it up two three four
Wait here for the captain and his squad then get your ass inside
Get your ass
Okay, let's move
Up two trees power up two trees power
Fast forward
Play
Which is weird, right? I mean look at it something scrambled the insides
Alien plasma scoring. Yeah, I don't know maybe there was an accident, you know friendly fire or something
What do we have sergeant?
Looks like a covenant patrol bad ass elite units all k.i.a. K.i. kill the nuts. Oh my god. I'm such a
soldier
Fast forward
Right, well, let's get this door open
I'll try sir, but it looks like these covenant work pretty hard to lock it down. Just do it son
This is what Cortana didn't want them to open but he did
Then they just see forward it. Okay real and true though. Oh, right. Sorry. I missed it
I like the check in the the area like left right left right walk
Got a bad feeling about this
Boy, you always got a bad feeling about
What's going on soldier
We have more than one enemy
Corporal do you copy over there's more than one enemy in this game
And those that gets your ass back up to second squads position and find out what the hell is going on
I don't have time for your lip soldier. I gave you an order. Oh, I hear it
What is it? What is that?
Where's that coming from Mendoza?
I don't there
Oh
Hold still let them have it
There are too many sorry, let's think about it
Wait sergeant did
Everyone died
I
Shotgun shotgun, please are you shotgun shotgun any shotgun so be so be scared don't be scared. Are you shotgun? No, there's no shotgun
Like I wanted one
The mid-kit random mid-kit, okay
I'm gonna stop. Oh
Oh my god
How do I have ammo?
How do I have enough ammo for this there's no way there's so tiny an intricate
Is this uh Danny to run? Ah
There's more coming from the ray
Please no no no no no no no no no no no no no I can't do this. I can't do this. I can't do this
I actually can I can I'm sorry. I'm skipping. It's a dead end. It's a dead end. Don't skip don't skip. Oh
It's okay. It's okay
Please if you could all grip up in a manually order so I can show you
The most efficient way possible that would be great
As if there's not enough enemies in this game, please
As if there isn't enough in this game
And there's big big ones big
Oh
My god stop stop you're scaring me
Let's let's stop spawning in for a second. Let's stop spawning in for a second. Okay
oh stop it please please stop spawning in for a millisecond do I come back the
way I came I don't I don't know did I go the way I came okay there's loads of
red dots on the map but I didn't see them I don't I don't see them but I see
little red dots everywhere the lesser people's version of legend they insta
kill you how it says or something right there I'm stop stop stop look at all
those red doors checkpoint done how what do you mean done I've never even done
anything look I'm scared I swear if I turn these corners in there they are
stop why why I'm scared oh my god there's red on me
stop where are they it says they're on me oh they're there oh my gosh my heart
I can actually pop them from here okay okay okay yeah I'm fucking running with
them too how did I get out here or is it like is it actually just a slaughter how
did I get out here the store oh my god stop there's one coming over though I saw
yes oh please tell me there's no more of this game I am stressed I am stressed with a
capital S right now I can't handle this I really need this game would like please tell
me there's not another I can oh my god oh my god oh my god there's a shotgun please please
just give it and don't get don't don't ask don't ask I'm using the shotgun reflin said
you're shotgun I'm using shotgun you don't have to fucking tell me twice okay okay this
is there's only one mission of this and I don't need to go against them again it's fine I don't
need to go against them again after I've done this one mission that's the good news they
only have one of these because they're sick and they're perverted ways trying to scare
checkpoint done okay okay okay wait why are we going farther down no I want to go up
I want to go up I want to go up I want to go up I want to go up I want to go up I want to see
sunlight these things don't live in sunlight clearly they would dry up like a little balloon
oh my god I feel like I'm wasting so much ammo because like sprays be so much better oh my god
hundred percent only mission like this trust okay good real and true and faith faith restored
faith given trust given I'm going to edge and feel like I'm gonna throw up I'm not even kidding
I'm so scared oh my god please let me still through this where I'm at to go oh no the bridge
holy I'm actually so nervous right now I feel like I'm gonna hurt myself
please please don't uncork in the middle of this please oh my god they're everywhere
please stay cloaked forever please just forever stay cloaked oh just stay cloaked for a hundred
billion minutes that's all I ask it's a simple request please don't uncork I don't know where to
go please don't uncork please don't uncork is this a dead end surely this is dead end
much to jump on it I'll jump on it
ah
where are you going up up oh my god go up go up go up go up get up mr. John
stop it you're scaring me stop it you're
stop it's too much it's too much it's too much I'm putting this all right for it it's too much it's
it's too much it's too close combat stop it's too close combat what was it what was it
stop if you listen closely the zombie monsters will sometimes ask you to help
they'll ask me to help why they're the baddies I'm the goodie why would they ask me for help
oh my god I can hear them oh my god I can hear them stop stop this is too creepy oh my god I need
to call my dad so he can finish this game for me what the fuck I can finish this game
I've already been here I've already been here I've already been here it's a dead end there's no
other green there's no other green unless I have to go down there okay logical logical yes logic
logic logic I am john halo I am the real john halo I can do this I can do this I am john halo
and I have halo combat halo in but okay yep mm-hmm mm-hmm mm-hmm it's okay that you keep
maintaining corridors with obstacles in the way so I'm getting trapped on everything that's okay I
forgive you game developers who designed this course label I forgive you I forgive you for
experimenting with map design you are forgiven for your sins against humanity you are forgiven for
the glass constantly breaking under my feet you are forgiven you are not free of sin but you're
forgiven on the list how do I get across please open up the bridge I'm going across the bridge
one is only one map like this and I don't ever have to play the map again I don't ever have to
play the pop again I don't have to play the map again there's no other map like this there's no
other map like this all the copium days all the copium days all the copium days taking it back
upstairs all the copium days thank you stash power super chat I'm not gonna make it I'm not gonna
make it okay there's grunt
thank you reverses uh project one point speaks to me out as well so
here's what your composition find a way above the fog and move in and pick you up say no more
give me the shocker drill okay let's go let's go back to the drop ship I can't wait to get off
this planet and never have to come back again oh yeah what's that there's multiple red dots
closing in on our position right now oh yeah I sure hope it won't be the thing
ah it's not the covenant anyway I can tell you that much
for once the covenant isn't the problem who to thumb
it's less scary because I have back up now I may have bent the truth a bit or like a lot
reef link yeah it's pain I'll make it okay reef links which is mama blowing out first
your eardrums with her jumps carry actions or your back with her tentacle after stream
uh actually real and true whoa I'm missing a lot the wee ones okay I feel better because I have
back up rock opium oh sorry I can't see thank you really for losing
uh like I didn't realize halo was a horror game because I was kind of like oh he ha
in the car wait where's my jet where I was gonna say where's my gen mates as if they're fighting
with me in halo right now did they all die am I on my own again I am so lost I don't know where to go
I hear
what's going on
bro
either you're gonna die from the flood or me shitting you try and take it off of you
I'm alone again thank you tiny spainy I'm so sorry all right where where are you
huh what's going on is there code and messed up
oh my god oh my god I'm gonna actually have a heart attack
you're the master chief solider hold 5k I don't want it I don't want it I don't want the title
of master chief the best assistant shooter you know I don't want like an accolade or gold
medal or brave medal or any of those kind of things I just want oh my god best remake tour
shooter with us okay I'm trying I'm trying where are we to go what's this it's a beacon pick us up
now oh there's the red over there okay right follow the red copy on follow the red follow the red
this is where I'm supposed to go I know follow the red follow the red okay there's more enemies on
the map okay I can handle like open and multiple allies that's fine what I can't handle is the
really thin corridors where you're getting trapped on stuff trying to run away
what that sound is very clearly
what
oh sorry I'm sorry ma'am I don't know what the fuck what is it
no don't shoot the drones yet it's a spark
other friends that need to talk to it
what
follow it
did I have a glitch it out
follow the drone
make sure everything is safe
uh I think I might have bugged it because of the safe
hello you said oh hello your dad
oh
I thought you were a woman
oh he just kidnapped me okay um do you not know what he said
John
okay
I don't know what to make her heads or tails bathroom break time trust me wait I need a pee so
welcome the worst mission of the game you'll be on your own the entire time
no no should I pee first before I do this one unironically because I will piss myself
and stop even the violent strings are getting eerie
okay yes go pee
oh my thank you for the gift of 20
I'm not really on my own right I need to pee I'm gonna go pee I'm scared don't make me
thank you math for this many gifts this is it the memberships and congrats to those who
got away their face I'm sorry I'm scared I literally stink a bill right now because I've
been sweating so much okay give me one second I'll thank all and then we're gonna do a bit more
hail with
I thought how many missions are there I thought this was an easy game
rare right brb
you
sorry Strone was asking for cashers
oh
in papa cuddles but um Strone's got me wrapped around her little bird finger
don't bomb it I'm already vomit and try to play get through the game
oh I put the heating on it's actually quite cold I don't want it to be too cold for
Yimla and Beagle
oh
thank you again math for the gift of 20 gifts and congrats to those who called it
thank you doomsday dad no alessandro zarian kalker
stash power
hey mama I hope you don't hold anything against libraries after this
libraries just a tip just keep running it isn't worth it to stand and fight on this level
okay just run this we're going to a library
they're already there they're already there right don't don't don't shoot okay okay don't shoot
not soon they have boomers aren't those those left for dead two things
are you sure I shouldn't be fighting right now
what is that oh my god that's a gap oh my god are you sure
oh are you sure I should be running
oh my god the wrong way did I go the wrong way
sugar sugar oh my god they exploded reveal more oh my god they reveal oh don't look back
I'm gonna I'm actually gonna throw up oh my god don't look back it's fine oh my god stop
certain areas what are you doing let me in and you have to wait at other areas
oh my god you should have done it half an hour ago
I'm the fucking door you're bad
oh my god I'm hiding in the corner bro I'm literally I'm not having to circle enemies
just the john thanks for the super chat oh my god I'm done I'm done I'm not gonna make it
not gonna make it literally did not make it I'm perished oh my god you could open them doors half
an hour ago you cheeky bam honestly honestly me take a left or a right if you if you pick left
you brought such an effective weapons to combat the bug despite the containing protocols I bra
bro I'm gonna where where are you going you've just left me on my own I'm not gonna make it
stash power certain areas they've just respawn oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god stop it
oh my god I love the shotgun so much it's actually a gun that feels like it's heavy
you know like has a blast it probably me alone am I on the right way Danny go down there
Danny go down there be honest I'm about to do a big 360 no I'm trying I hear you I don't see you
come down to my freaking level
yes yes yes later later later oh my god how are they exploding uh
oh
remember we love you and you can get through this okay good luck okay I love you too darling
oh my there's a supplement your combat systems but I suggest you replace what leaves the
bro come back
it's this room supposed to be
this room supposed to be
you want the heart rate on
I have it here I have it here I can put it on
all right you need to lick it
over or not hold on if you want the heart rate it should automatically register
oh my god I stink of B.O like I'm fucking weak in because of how much I've been sweating
I just showed you my boobs sorry I had to lift up my hoodie it's just my boobs are in your face
pheromones yay I think we're past pheromones unfortunately
okay
is it gonna work
oh I woke up hold on my track I need to go off just for a moment I think
oh plosoid your ass is really hard to resist and I can't let you see it
P for plosoid P P for plosoid I literally cannot find it
wait what
no here it is I got it I got it got it got it can we lick this well it is actually weak in
like I could you know it's weak in
wait it says no heart wait it bleeped I literally heard it bleeped did you go offline be honest
we put this shit I'm not done with you yet
might have to turn off
oh there I don't know if you heard that beeping scan for the heart rate monitor
device connecting uh the bluetooth device is uh connected
am I gonna need to register a bit better than that
let me hold on let me
there's no test that's actually working okay that I mean I guess
I don't feel that relaxed I don't know about you but I don't feel relaxed okay
we're going back that should be my heart rate oh well that looks much more like it
no heartbeat literally bleep it be beeping gaming kitsune thank you for the super chat gimli
you're just hi gimli if you want to help me defeat the flyers you have to come up on my lap
I don't think you're gonna like what follows gimli I'm gonna be honest I think you're gonna
be scared I'm gonna start screaming in a second I don't think gimli's gonna be happy
I mean I'm not happy I've got to freaking bob and weave through all of this hello hi
I don't like uh I really don't lot of activity has caused a failure you're in a drone control
I must be so oh geez please continue on I will enjoy you when I've completed my task
you're you're wait what we're I'm I'm to go on my own from here
hold your position until the monitor returns what position oh my god drones please
drones please please laser a bit faster and harder that would be appreciated
please an upgrade I'll take anything because what the heck please how long did I need to stay here
like this I only have 30 name bullets
sorry I heard a sound effect to the right of me
okay I'm just throwing an aid out
bro for AI that's so good oh my god oh he's back he's back he's back okay okay he's fine
he's back they're attacking the mojito
oh my god I can hardly see him I genuinely can hardly hear him
I'm one option survive
stop honestly because I'm like skipping them I don't think I'm as freaked out right now
but I kid you not that other mission where they unlocked uh
okay
bro
right as long as my shield isn't gone I got worked a little bit keep an eye out for shotgun ammo
I don't even see any you mind another door right another door I can handle another door surely
please wait here where are you going combine dolly melon
oh I'm not gonna make it oh they're coming oh no I don't have an assault rifle wait why
what are they locking on to
oh well that glitch went really well keep doing more of what that is
they can't only keep from afar if you don't think about it too much
I imagine she's got to reboot the wafer where's john heel when you need him
I don't know
okay if I just if this is the like last mission where I just need to do the thing then I'll be okay
thought how are you shooting me you're literally wait where did he go
where did he go
I'm to go down there
there are more I think the next one is actually worse for me
this is what I meant about small confined spaces
in the flood okay don't don't don't give me any more of whatever that was don't do it I'm not
no one
it's fine it's fine it's fine I have aimbot
they have really claimed a lot of the common arms I don't know what I've been told
I'm fucking please tell me those laser beams are coming
oh I can't um I I feel sick in my throat
but if you could hurry us along to the location
as fortunately I um a living organism carbon-based life form I ain't gonna make it cheap if you
don't hurry your ass up and get me to where I need to be
I've entered the battle dome apparently they're all gonna start coming out of an AMAR oh my god
we're out of the halo gun again literally the halo shotgun but I don't want to ride the elevator
is the name of this mission so to say um just be shitting my pantyloons is a bit of an understatement
right now because what does that mean hi again oh I don't have ammo for this
we're releasing the plug they see most persistent in their attempts to access restricted areas get back down
okay if the wee planes want to come with me that'd be great just stay with me honestly
oh he got back up again hold on
are you down for real this time I don't like it I don't like tight little corridors this is
this is literally why I don't like tight corridors stop it literally why I I freaking called it I freaking
called it they know what the dev team knew exactly what they were
oh
anyway I was saying the dev team knew exactly what the heck they were doing
oh my god get me out of this heck hole where am I to go take an educated guess
oh it got up again oh don't do that okay I need more of these laser beams
all laser beams please all the time I need more ammo
I'm trying to act like this is fine I just know it's dire is it did I go the wrong way
right this is a definitely a dead end so the other way go the other way go the other way
go the other way going the other way going the other way going the other way
halo combat evolve doesn't have sprint and that's okay
it's not but I have to pretend it's okay
hold your position until the monitor returns
can I get help from the sentinels or do I need to run back around to the sentinels
hello sentinels do you want to follow me here buddy here puppy
come on come help come help daddy john daddy join needs some help because he's not got ammo
because the devs aren't putting any ammo down
he's literally okay there I've got ammo
please keep laser beaming
just laser beam everything I don't want to see anything by the end I want to be completely
blind okay surely okay checkpoint done so I'm moving on sorry I'm I don't know if that's
cheesy doodle in or they should be following me but like I'm not gonna make it I'm not gonna make
it I'm not gonna make it
so
I'm gonna please open faster
please
oh my god I'm died I'm dying now thank you
as if they can shoot they're like zombies
oh my god they're faster than me
bro I'm gonna need your laser beams I'm gonna need to order 10 I don't care how many smacker
runes they cost I'm gonna need like pronto I'm gonna need I'll put myself on the delivery
line if I have to on the production line give me them
there's oh my god they're literally growling at me please how is this not over
how is this worse there are zombies with aim button stalled okay that's even worse thank you but
that's worse is worse
stop it you're scaring me is this the end of the line
no okay I can go in further
I'm gonna please how is anyone supposed to play this game on legendary mode
am I alone at least
you know what I spoke too soon because why would they why would they why would
they actually be so nice to me
I don't understand how I'm supposed to juke them
this this is such a small area
oh
we got up
help help help help help help help no help no help no help on my own on my own
oh my god open up faster I can't
oh my god
do you mean oh my god he's opening he's opening
open faster please oh my god please please just laser everything oh my god
UV rays any tape or laser and I'll take it laser hair removal will work too
fuck it smack that shit on top okay please stay close time be sure I
he's trolling right please stay close and he's going halfway across the map
oh my god don't ever make me play Halo I was like oh I'm gonna play Halo 2 and then 3 probably
and oh dear he's leaving to Halo Wars as well
fuck that shit are you joking me I'm terrified go away please leave me alone
this is literally a horror game
yes please mummy Halo reach three is good fourth floor tools guns keys to super weapon
oh my god oh my god Halo 2 is less scary they'd cooked on combat of all did they purposefully
want it to be this scary or was it just like tee he like I'm about to read a developer's
interview after I play this game oh he just perished on the way down he took fall damage
aim because like there's only so much one can take
oh they dropped me ammo nuisance
I think I need to go down here oh yay my favorite thing a nice tight fucking no turn corridor
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I ain't gonna make it I'm not gonna make it no it's glitch
okay well well oh my god I'm so good at dodging how the how on earth does anyone play legendary
this is not possible if they insta kill you with a touch how how do you win on legendary you don't
it's just suffering that's what you win do you want to suffer while you play video games
I have a great suggestion for you but seriously how I can hear him please open this door what's
going on if you let's shout oh my gosh yeah you guys weren't kidding when you said it's infinite
one it's just a wee bit hard honestly
am I not supposed to be here nothing's happening
am I going the wrong way oh right okay no no it's fine you're just waiting on you for ages anyway
no more please leave me alone
for me it's hard to feel scared when I'm playing as a death machine that destroys everything in my
past all I'm asking is for two assistant birds okay two assistant laser beams I'll be happy
what it's repairing my shit how
oh sorry
uh take a whack
that is insane what do you want from me oh my god
what does it want what is the flood one actually well we're on the subject of what do you want
do they want to take over everything
oh
it wants to consume to spread
every person they in fact they steal all they know like knowledge
they want to eat everything they want to spray cramber I have not heard that mean in ages
I don't know why it was so popular
what was the
was that supposed to happen
protocol requires that I take possession of the index for transport your organic form
rather too vulnerable to infection the index must not fall into the hands of the
flood before you use the room and activate the installation the flood is spreading we must hurry
so that's that bad mission over right
he yanked it literally brov got me to do it but then he takes it give you cheeky exam honestly
which means that any organism with sufficient mass and cognitive capability is a potential doctor
I mean you're not wrong but no nothing splendid shall we
no uh nothing
so what we're gonna use the halo ring in the way
with my classification to perform a task as important as the reunification of the index
so then give me back the thing
okay I feel like that may have been cut content or something now it takes it from
us next cut scene gives us a back
oh really
I've spent the last 12 hours cooped up in here watching you tody about helping that thing get
set to slit our throat hold on now he's a friend oh I didn't know he's your pal is he damn Cortana
any idea what that bastard almost made you do yes activate halo's defenses and yes
which is why we brought the index to the control center you mean this
a construct in the core that is absolutely unacceptable wait so he's a buddy what
I shall hurt you at once you sure that's a good idea
how how do you what they're having like a little robot war the index you can just float and
sputter enough I mean I'm on Cortana's side but you have no idea how this ring works do you
why the forerunners built it halo doesn't kill flood it kills their food humans covenant whatever
we are all equally edible the only way to stop the flood is to starve them to death the ring
is exactly what halo is designed to do wipe the galaxy clean of all sentient life you don't
believe me ask him we just about nuked everyone I'm just a grunt following orders I don't know what
you're on about
he doesn't even care as a maximum of more less than 25,000 light years but once the others follow
suit this galaxy will be quite a lot of life or at least any life with sufficient violence
to sustain the flood I mean yeah
sort of baseline and are they can I say something controversial was the development team british
by any chance as we manage this crisis I'm getting a vape though the rubric
I may just make that up we need to go right now last time you asked me if it were my choice
would I do it having had considerable time to ponder your query my answer is not changed
there is no choice we must activate the ring can I shoot the bowl get us out of here if you are
unwilling to help I will simply find another still I must have the index is he about to turn
on me I will be forced to take her from you that's not going to happen so weird save us and dispose of
the rest look out why is this my weapon
and let's try buddy what's laser at least like a mad really bad disco in the lakes are malfunctioning
what's this funky tune is playing we can't let the monitor activate halo we have to stop him we
have to destroy halo according to my analysis of the available data I believe the best course
size will help destabilize the ring and we'll cut through a number of primary systems we need to
trigger a detonation on a large scale however starships fusion reactors going critical
how could the guilty spark be so guilty to search what's left of the
covenant battle night and see if I can locate the pillar of this music is so funky though I'm not
fusion reactors are still relatively intact we can use them to destroy halo
door time I press e on a door to open it yes yes yes I'm so smart
wait so the covenants never the problem wait these are going to turn on us yeah is this a
coming in not now can you guys oh right okay this is one of the things that I have a great
with it's when two enemies are fighting you enter the room and they both look at you as if you're
the problem and they were literally just tearing each other apart moments before stop it stop it
oh my shield stone hold on let me just get my shield back one second
I need my shield miss the shotgun the new one just doesn't feel congrats you now have no allies at all
literally enter a room
um
I am prefiring oh I guess that was a waste uh I thought there was going to be an enemy that
pops out and goes behind them you're doing pretty good am I
I have no idea like how far we are through or anything like that
in case the monitor or his sentinels find a way to activate halo's final weapon without the index
ain't a free bug the machinery in these cannons are halo's primary firing mechanisms they consist
of three phase pulse generators that amplify halo's signal and allow it to fire deep into space
the power levels are enormous I can't even begin to calculate the pulses range wait there wasn't
even anything up here so if we damage or destroy these generators the monitor will need to
wait there's only four billets some time oh there's not enough billets for his pulse generator with
a nav point we need to move in you're about the latter half getting close to the end fancy time
okay time to drive
no you don't want to hurt halo don't heal from the hit video game halo no get the pistol actually
wait where is my does he even know where my banshee is or did it get despawned I feel like
this mission is like far too big
yeah I don't have a banshee
but that aimbot is terrible
where is banshee
no one asks how is banshee but where is banshee
oh god that is green
oh I found it it's over there
does that hurt my shield I didn't expect that
is that gonna hurt me too if I messed up I think I'm about to lose health
unless I can hate and get my shield back
I'm such a stealth assassin
I got stolen shouldn't have parked in such a bad neighborhood on
as if there's a race
as if there's a race just waiting it's not gonna like get me right it's not gonna get me right
it's clearly don't get to get me right up get up get up up up up up up up up up up up up up up
okay
okay I think we're safe oh no we're not what the heck how do you control this
I want to shoot um before a lunge what the heck this is so odd
that's very odd driving how do you even use those in multiplayer when you have to like try
and kill other people John 117 Master Chief is a great character you mean John Halo from Fortnight
I'm trolling before anyone is like
what's this
that's the pulse generator the center core
we need to interrupt the pulse generator's energy stream I've adjusted your shield system
so that it will deliver an EMP burst to disrupt the generator that you'll need to walk into the
beam to trigger it the EMP blast should neutralize the generator but what to do
ah
uh-huh the generator's central core is offline well done oh peace off
oh peace off
am I done
I'm done
that's Johnny I got someone to listen to the hypnosis they want to work
the adjacent canyon okay
another throw another one to add to my pooch
why is this so hard to steer oh my gosh
I absolutely have no comprehension on how I'm supposed to drive those
gotta run for a bit have a good night enjoy yourself love you Ethan
take it easy I'm freaking playing a horror game well actually I feel better because we're just
hanging with the covenant I definitely I can't believe I'm seeing this about the enemy
but yeah controversial take I prepare the covenant
then the flood because the flood are terrifying
what am I doing other than par 4 right now where am I supposed to go
then everything but where I'm supposed to go no convention controversial am I going to the way I
just came yeah okay right I'm not supposed to go there yet until I'm wanting to
the adjacent is how I learned what I meant oh that's what happened in a lot of video games
for me I was like oh that's what that word means I'm not going to look to the
to
sorry hold on I'm I'm being a bit slow right now I'm not
but not like a power thing here this or something
oh here we go
yeah okay there we go okay okay we're doing it we're doing it we're doing it sorry sorry just
leave me a little bit longer than the average person for something to click but we get there in a
I do love like quick ones
wait hold on how fast can I
uh terribly slow wait wait wait wait out of curiosity
if I can do this really fast I don't know
oh it's not working what the heck I thought it was like
hmm I wasn't really doing what I wanted to do you know I did math effect sometimes
to start out the controversy of shepherd versus she
oh no I jinxed it what the heck
I jinxed it no I literally was seeing how happy I was to go against the covenant
and I don't know what to do
I don't know what to do
please leave me alone in a respectful way not a mean way
please how am I you're how am I the problem if there's
oh my god stop
if there's literally the flood cutting about how am I the problem
these are all getting farted on seriously how does this keep happening
right these guys pretend to die and get back oh my god oh my god nope nope nope nope nope nope
oh my god you can jump where I can jump as well and maybe not as high but oh my god
stop
oh have I gone too far I don't know how am I on a bridge uh am I supposed to be here
I don't know there's more I mean if they coded more enemies to be on the bridge then yeah I guess
okay the government and the flutter are oh my god could you be any more scarier
there's nothing worse than when the jump animation actually isn't animated and you can just see it come into
you in 4k and you've no got you've no got a clue you're going the right way okay just keep running
you don't have to tell me twice reflin you don't have to don't worry about me I am treating myself
to take away after this freaking stream because brah my heart I thought oh this is literally
John Wick all over again oh I'm gonna play a rooty tootie game I'm gonna watch a rooty tootie movie
the movie in the game the most like awful terrifying horrific thing of our cooling thank you for
becoming a member please enjoy the moats I am getting more moats I promise the pregnancy
and the the puke and moat and all that is gonna get a bit of an upgrade thank you for the direct
support cooling are the calling I have no idea of cooling as the cooling
oh just get me in the middle of the map so I can get here oh my god I can't there's
there's things smashing everywhere oh my god oh my god I can't
this is fine this is saying this is fine it's okay it's just fine it's as fine this is fine
this is fine am I going this is fine this is fine this is fine
No, no, no, no, no wait what got me he has a
RPG how far back did you send me what
bridge okay I'm on the right bridge he
has an RPG did you see that I'm on the
right bridge or this wrong bridge he
literally had an RPG what must we do that
stop it
wait am I back I'm a rocket floods did I
ban you land on her possible oh my god I'm
so sorry for me did I lose any progress
then have I been here or I can't tell if
I lost progress or not what the fuck is
that noise did you hear that it was like
I'm going the wrong way I wondered why
everything was dead
ah mummy's trying reflin mummy's trying
so hard but she sucks it's the river
football is getting close I can hear
like falcon or something from it at
least you have more ammo now I picked up
one bullet you cheeky sod I picked up
one bullet and you know I picked up one
bullet let's get right into the news and
buy news sucking is a good thing though
real the level breaks just about
everyone no matter how many times you do
it yeah I have to admit can you at least
give me like a red bridge and a blue
bridge so I know I'm not like going the
same way for the billion time
loading done why are you loading I've
done this before haven't all right leave
me alone for one two oh your mom what is
this oh it's just a room for me to get
stuck in in close combat oh my gosh oh
my gosh right okay oh my god I'm getting
I'm getting wallet oh my god please I
would very much like to reshield
nah I've no got this I've no got this I
didn't even want me doing
I actually not gonna make it not gonna
make it
oh I literally can't finish this game on
legendary difficult okay okay rocket
launcher get ready here get ready here
everyone on this bridge get the heck out
of here I'm no having it I'm no having it
I'm no having it everyone get out I don't
care I'm not getting rocket launched
halfway across the map don't do it I
don't know where it is but you it was
you
that was you I got him I got my revenge
strongies revenge don't ever rocket launch
me the bridge is closed exactly you've
killed 10k of them you're doing great
what are you also look at them just waiting on me
well well things you that's supposed to
happen I don't know
please don't do that please oh well there
goes my health
okay checkpoint yes yes checkpoint are
going to
don't do that they're not that don't do it I
don't know why I don't know I'm gonna
save can you touch the walls I don't
know I don't know I don't know I don't
know I don't know
please don't do that that's not really
nice that's okay don't do that again
You understand me?
Is that the wall?
Oh look at this!
No!
Monk.
Oh it's a dead end. I love finding the dead end.
Oh my god, I should find all the dead ends in this game for fun.
Just for the hell of it.
Nice death. Nice death. No. We'll watch the clip again and again.
Abra. If you use the clip in my desk, I'll get Arista to make it short of me just going
like every time I die. Wait, am I to walk into this? I don't know. I don't know. I don't
know what the answer is. Oh my god, they're like greveling at me. I don't know where
to go. I'm stuck in this room? Wait, how did I come in? No. I'm not stuck. I'm being
silly. Okay, but what's the actual answer though? What must I do? Is this the way I
came? This stuff all looks the same. Oh no, it says checkpoint. Okay, it says checkpoint.
We're winning. Let's take care of the next pulse generator. Okay, pulse generator. I love
pulse generators. I love pulsing all over a generator. I'm going to pulse so badly on
the generator. I'm about to get knocked out. Okay. Okay. Okay. I need this. Give me that.
I need it to get across the chasm. I need you to pulse my gen. Okay, well that didn't
work. How is the flood out here in the cold? Come on. Don't you get like hypothermia or
something? Your miserable bams, honestly. Weird. What am I supposed to do? Get up there.
In order to do that. Oh my god, am I at the distance for them? No, I can't be. I must be.
Where's the goat? Yeah, at the bench. Please pulse on me. She pulsed on my generator until
I overloaded. Honestly, that's absolutely. How or where? This? No, that's just the four
of them. Look at them all at the wall. Is one of them raiding that? What? Oh, come on.
I literally thought one of the wee floods were raiding that. Don't be so silly. What was
that? That literally was so rude. Sorry. That was so rude. I thought a wee flood was on
it. Right. No, yous are all getting ignored because you're wasting my time. How am I supposed
to get up there? Do you mind? I'm literally on foot. Sorry, I can't seem to figure out
what I'm supposed to do to get up. Am I supposed to go back? Like this way? Quickly. Oh my god.
Am I supposed to go this way? No, this is where I came in the tank. Is it? I'm so sorry.
I'm a bit turned around right now. Is it this? Yeah, no, I'm supposed to go this way. Okay.
Thank god you guys are gamers. I'll let you guys be the gamer. I'll just commentate over
your gameplay. What a strange, strange map. Checkpoint done. Okay. Why is it giving me loads
of nades? This makes me nervous. Maybe just a reload station. The whole game is kind of
a forward than a backward. Okay. Alright. I'm so confuzzled but it's okay. Wait. No, keep
going, keep going. Everything looks like a dead end in this game and then it's not and
it should be Banshee closer to where you need to get going. Checkpoint done. I need my glasses
on. I need to start gaming with my glycs, honestly. Okay, hunters, that's fine. If they only shoot
from afar, can I outrun them completely? Honestly, that looks like some Harry Potter magic when
Harry and Olivia's off. I'm going to just let yous do your thing. We're going to agree
to disagree. I don't need to die. Go up the middle part. Oh no, middle part and this is
locked. Is that a wraith when I'm on foot? Come on. I see lights over here. No point in
suffering because I can't even see. Oh yeah, yous. What the fuck? I'm literally on foot.
Don't auto lock to me, you freak. Let me deal with you first, you bam. Give me the plane.
Give me it. Okay, well, I can't take it now because I destroyed it. That's a bit overkill.
Come on, I'm literally just a guy. What are you aiming at? Can it not aim at me properly?
Oh well, we solved that fucking case, didn't we? Oh my god, stop moving. I'm going to cry.
Please stop moving. Much more like it. Right, where the heck is this banshee that I'm supposed
to do? Because I aim bot. Run. Nah, you can't steal banshees once they're gone. Oh, there
is, there is. I found it, I found it. Don't worry. You stop shooting at me. You leave me
alone. I'm just going in the sky. I'm sending it. I'm sending it. Sorry, I'm going. It's
not my concern what you guys do on the ground. I'm part of the air superior, you know.
Okay, up, up, up, and then along.
Oh, it's right. Let's get out. Woo! That's why we're getting out as soon as we can.
Okay, we did it. We did it. Checkpoint complete.
Loading. Okay, I'm going to have one, one review about this game. I know they were so
limited with memory space and what the actual console could do, but this is getting very
incredibly samey. I'm struggling to be like, I don't know what to do as soon as I enter
this location. It's all chaos and terrible and everything's awful and I've just killed
myself, I think. Oh wait, I'm to walk into this. Okay.
Bro, I'm dead. I'm actually dead.
I don't... Is this where I came from?
I don't know how I'm doing this. I really don't, darlings, I really don't. Oh my God,
my ghost is literally, I'm even, it's going to drop me.
Oh, it's fucking getting this before I can't. I don't know how to freaking drive these.
It's so bizarre. Like, it's honestly so bizarre.
Excuse me. Where am I to go? Damn. Hold on, I'm going to swap for a banshee that isn't
freaking... Am I actually supposed to go down or am I being trolled right now? Did you beat
me? No, I suck.
Let's go down.
If you switch weapons on the banshee, you can get a bomb.
Uh, I can skip all the fights because I'm flying. Love it here. I love a good flight
skipping. Don't mind if I do.
Oh, really? Hold on. Right, ready? And then get back in.
Oh shit.
How come they figure out what I want to do every time?
How come they go like, aww, she finally has it a bit easier. Let's make sure she can
take the banshee into the next area. How come the game devs always do that to me?
Like, just say you hate me. And none of this aww, then he take it personally, then he...
No, I'm taking it personal. 3, 4, 3? No! Literally, no. I'm not... I'm... I'm raging.
I'm raging! You fucking witch, you are scary. I'm just getting mad now.
You wish you were scary, but you're not him. You will never be him.
You will never be John Halo from the hit video game Halo.
I'm already out of Granada's, but I've got to think...
They are handicapping you because you're too good, exactly.
Yeah, partially I'm out of ammo.
Rip. RIP.
From Fortnite?
Raging? I thought you were scouting.
Is this legendary difficulty? It is! It is!
I'll let Sheldon 360s on legendary and everything.
Is this one going to fall apart? Nope, I could fit a banshee through it if I wanted to.
If I so desired, I could fit the chunkiest, juiciest, fattest banshee through that doorway.
No lube.
It's called the final run, a bloody opse, so...
I can't even take any more, my wee heart's going to pop its wee clogs.
Destroy Pulse Gen 3, rip.
Let's ignore the fight and let's get down to what we actually need to do.
Which is, we need to fly.
And in order to fly, we must find the secret banshee.
Sorry, Strony, there's more. No!
I'm going to expire! I'm going to expire midstream.
No! No!
Hello?
What was that?
I already expired, literally, called it to say we're hand on the fucking...
I said I'm going on a supermarket simulator.
At least this supermarket simulator gave me nice to me.
I'm like you.
Brave.
Did it have a RPG?
Okay.
Okay, I see how it is.
I see how it is.
Not to be confused with Hit V Trooper or AC Snow Claws.
Right, I've killed this banshee for the third time now.
This game needs to give it a rest.
Just give me the banshee!
Just give me the banshee.
No need, I'm out.
Look how long it took those, but then when I do it...
I'm stuck, no I'm not.
Did they already come out or am I about to be rocket launched for the billionth time?
Stop, I literally just saw all three of those.
Please!
Please let me win.
Who's got the RPGs?
You need to be put down right now.
Seriously, whoever's got the RPGs needs to be put down right now.
Why are you sh-
I'm not gonna make it.
Okay.
He was talking to himself.
Right, okay.
I need to go find the freaking banshee so I can get the heck off of this ground.
Because it's cursed.
I don't even see it over there.
Or am I to go through the cavern?
Is there a lore behind the nickname Mom?
It's not really that deep, it's just how you see it in a Scottish accent.
And I'm kinda seen as a bit motherly.
And it was a nice nickname so it stuck.
So now I'm called Mom.
But you can smell it like M-O or M-E.
M-E-A, sorry.
Sorry, I don't know my freaking words.
Right.
Give it a rest!
My heart can't eat this anymore.
I've got a checkpoint for that.
I don't know how I didn't do anything, but...
I'll beat it.
Mommy is Mom.
And then you're my little reflans.
Every time I do that with the ghost, stop.
Right, well that couldn't have gone any worse if I tried.
That literally couldn't have gone any worse if I tried.
Oh, it's a dead end!
Lovely, dead end.
Right, stop flipping over this fucking ghost, honestly.
I need the Banshee, wherever it is.
What is it when I get something that mildly aids me in my conquest?
Is this what I'm supposed to do?
Checkpoint.
Okay, it is.
Grab the spanker and spanko.
Mommy's foolish woman that makes me blush Mom.
Oh my giat.
Sticking out your giat for the wrestler.
Your sensitivity.
You're so found and stuffed.
There's literally two reefs.
Bro, I'm sorry.
I'm jumping in them reefs and I'm going.
Bro, you can literally lick my starfish.
I'm not doing this right now.
I am not doing this right now.
No, don't run me over either.
Fuck you, honestly.
Get me in this Banshee!
Oh, please get me in the air right fucking now.
Go.
Oh my gosh.
How is I, I'm so sorry.
I'm going to have to watch someone play legendary.
That is insanity.
That is insane in the membrane, genuinely.
How?
I don't get it.
Get to the top.
Okay, we're here.
Thank the maker.
Please tell me this is the last mission.
Fuck off.
I'm not even, I've not even landed and you're going for me.
Get out of here.
Go away.
No, no, maybe this is better against them.
The flood is the shotgun, basically.
One pizza, of course.
They have shields, no!
When did they have shields?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, nice try mate.
Bonk.
Okay, was that three?
Bro, I'm getting laser beam today.
Relax.
Fuck you.
I'm shoving my arse in the gen.
Take that.
That's what I think of it.
Let's get out of here.
It's over.
Let's find a ride.
Good job now for the starfish.
No, it'll take too long.
You have a better idea.
There's a teleportation grid that runs throughout Halo.
That's how the monitor moves about today.
I learned how to tap into the grid when I was in the control center.
Unfortunately, each jump requires a rather consequential expenditure of energy.
Something tells me I'm not gonna like this.
But I'm pretty sure I can pull it from your suit without permanently damaging your shields.
Needless to say, I think we should only try this once.
Do it.
Cortana can't have beef for doing that.
She's good.
The Covenant Network is absolute chaos.
From what I've been able to piece together, their leadership ordered all ships to abandon
Halo when they found the flood.
I'm shoving my arse in the generator because it's the first thing that would reach my butt.
She...
Is this it?
Is this submission?
Oh, I see.
The Covenant data needs to be...
Right.
Sorry.
Is this the last mission?
Did we do it?
I hear the Halo music.
It's not my gun.
It's not my shot.
Don't do that!
I'm gonna pull a muscle in my shoulders at the rate I'm playing this game.
Oh my gosh.
They need to stop.
Stop with the tight corridors.
I'm begging.
I can't even handle it.
Give me that.
Gonna make me go against the flood.
At least give me a shot.
Ow.
That hurt.
This is the second last mission.
Oh!
What?
Oh.
Wait.
I was supposed to do that?
Was that...
That was supposed to be done, right?
Because I got cutscene, right?
Uh...
I can hardly see a thing in here.
I can see it easier in OBS than that actual game.
Okay, I was supposed to do that.
Okay, that's good.
I'll take that.
Where am I supposed to go?
I can't see nothing.
Oh.
I forgot.
I have a flashlight.
Let's get powered by my shoot...
Okay, yeah.
The...
I don't know what rape will seem best.
I'm just ignoring.
Sorry.
I don't have time for this.
You guys...
Woo!
Mama!
Why?
What a wonderful day.
You should go this way.
Towards the ship's gravity.
Land deal enemies!
To ruin my day!
Zip-a-dee-doo-da!
Zip-a-dee-doo!
I'ma need that healthcare-
No!
Okay, keep her going.
Keep her going.
Rrrrrr!
Rrrrrrrrr!
Rrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr!
Look at them smooth moves, smooth moves, love a bit of water, love a bit of water in
the map, this is raw copium we are working with, raw copium.
I freaking hope we were supposed to come down this way, I'm like about to run out of shotgun
ammo.
Let me in, hold your position, hold, hold, hold, weapons if you didn't make me hold
it and just teleported me up like right now, wouldn't that be so quirky if you didn't make
me defend and just let me go.
Okay that was so quirky of you, thank you, have a 10.
We should be able to get into the ship's control room from here, I can, there's only
two more to go, I can do it, it's fine.
Okay, okay, that's fine, oh they're coming by me as well, they're evolving, they're
evolving, they're evolving, they're evolving, for what, is that red, yep, he's gonna jump
back up, I'm gonna go please, no I don't want to assault rifle rounds, I want, I want
to show ease, oh my god, oh my god, okay well, okay what the actual fuck are you doing in
my house, this is impossible, this is impossible, the music isn't exactly helping you know keep
me up beat either about what's going on, oh my god please tell me this is the right way
because the door's open, I know the indicators tell me to go another way but I assume it's
like a, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, cheeky wee, cheeky wee, dead end, oh my god I love a dead end
I do, I really love it, they code it into the game, I absolutely adore it when you don't
just lock over the, okay, I love it, okay, the arrow and the gun is the compass, someone
told me it was no, I got spanked for thinking it was and I was like oh I'm just trying to
be a good girl, okay, I'm just trying to be a good girl and navigate this game, okay,
xee, oh my god why did they have to make this game so scary, why, I literally, oh let's
play a really McTuity shooty game, oh my god wouldn't that be so legit, oh my god, am I
going in circle, look in the corners, the flood are gathering bodies, am I just going
to run one big circle, huh, I thought I
always end up backwards, I'm like flabbergasted right now, okay, this is what happened last
time and then I went down that corridor that was open, well I'm going to have to go for
the dead bodies because they've got health on them, oh, why is there so many fucking
dead ends on this level, I've directionally challenged chromosomes, did I not go down
here and it was a dead end, or something, oh that's what I was supposed to do, yeah
sure, I was supposed to figure that one out real quick, bro, honestly how is that supposed
to figure out it's a freaking hole, only you would be able to do that, wait what, I'm sorry
I just think the game hates me, I literally need ammo of any accord, Covenant if we could
just join teams for a millisecond, who, who, who is anyone supposed to complete this game
if they're not in easy mode please, oh right, right, I'm not being funny, I'm not being
funny, I've been at this for like, go here do this, reverse the entirety of what you've
been going here to do, I don't even know where I'm going, I'm going down apparently, I don't
think I'm supposed to be going down, I'm supposed to be going up, I'm supposed to be going up
in that top corner, still not one friendly fire accident, by not using the assault rifle
it's a bad weapon on Legendary, I'm like having to guess where to go, I know the game's older
and they didn't have navigation like that but oh my god, someone's getting farted on it by the end
of this game, I don't know if it's the developers or you guys I'm farting on but someone's getting
am I going the wrong way, hand holding for modern game, literally, so this is locked so I'm going
the wrong way, who are you shooting at as if the flood's not being chillin' in here as I volunteer
I'm struggling after I admit, I'm struggling, right okay so this is just a look at the bottom
that you can randomly enter because why not, yep so all these are locked, I can't go in a hole,
okay I'm satisfied, so we're going to come out of here and we're going to go back up the stairs
that we came from, the game let us in
oh my god I need such a freaking shower after the stream, that view is
no you guys are like, we actually don't know how, we've never done it before
I'd never make you pull out that terrible, thank you basically was the tip, literally it was like
refling's pillow, we actually don't know how, we've never done it before
some of the dead ends provide a lore friendly spawning place, that's what I'm like 100%
convinced it is to drop, you get a rest
not even the gods could fill me a leg locked in, I do have strong legs, you're going to see
by the end of this week you'll see how my thighs look
okay give me that gun, 10 rounds for that
how is it, it seems almost ineffective, oh
just chaos, I know the good kind likes, I'm going to pop back up
oh my goodness, can't he manage it, can't cut it
oh
we're almost there, oh yes, we're almost there, and he still survived that, a freaking grenade
oh my god, chain mayor, else you believed, younger
this is a nightmare
hurry, how Cortana, please be so for real darlin, what am I looking at
oh my god, is there a part of the fucking thing
oh my god, you'll need an 80 min to pull me out, oh my god, pull me out, it's misery
no human life signs detected, the captain, he's one of them
that's a horror story, we can't let the flood get off this ring, you know what he'd expect
what he'd want us to do
oh
oh you're not even, bro, you're not even gonna take me out
no, go up my arsehole, honestly, take me back
the game's telling me I've been going the wrong way this whole time, oh and this is fun location
you're not gonna give me any advice, you're gonna tell me which direction to go in
and
at least wind and dive me before you fuck me so hard
please, where am I going, there's no indication, this, there's no ship, I'm going the wrong way
but I don't know where to go
okay it is here, apparently, unless that's just to be a drop ship, just upset me even more
because it's working, grab one of the escort vans and see the music to return to the robot
where, oh my god, you actually used the HUD for once, thank you Cortana, you're wet far
I'll actually let me hide under these, I'll let my thing go full
and then get out of my way, yabba bags, I'm out, bye, don't give a fuck
literally get me out, what a nightmare of a map, seriously
my brain's too strong, sorry, you need to splash yellow paint everywhere for me, you do, I don't
care if that makes me xyz or whatever, done and done, final level, here we go and the horse you
rode in on, what, go back home and the horse you rode in on
so
I'm gonna blow up the ship to blow up the ship, bro I'm gonna need you guys to blow my
fucking ring out after this one just to make me less angry
okay that's kind of funny though, yay the hardest level, don't, don't speak such things into
existence, I'm sure this will be the most clearly designed, oh my god it really is going backward
it really is going backwards, really, she's using, oh you, you, you bams you, oh I'm scared
oh and I just, I deserved it honestly, oh my god, this is 10 times worse than I could have
estimated, I'm gonna be honest, do I have a shotgun, nope you're not a shotgun, just to ruin my day
uh
bruh why, why, why, why
in me, I wanted that weight, something, something, something, why are you holding
a gun like that, drop it, bad grunt, over the please and I'm going the wrong way, yay I love
going the wrong way
this is a dead end, I'm not even supposed to be here
oh my god I have a crazy concept for the development team
stop making it possible to go in locations that are dead ends, checkpoint done apparently, well
it's not in right, it's just a shotgun
wait why did it just load
you're trolling right, you're having a funny ha ha right, I literally just cleared that out
but because I came too quickly, oh you got something against premature ejaculate, what the
fuck, I never loaded it because uh
oh I'm one health, sorry I'm about to die, I'm sorry I'm literally not paying attention
give me that one I guess
I'm literally just tonight, I'm fucking trolling
sorry, oh good, now the door opened, well we got health kit so
what worked katana, there's nothing here
hey
right we're in the bridge right, what happens next katana, come on then, come on then you
take the effect
what, what do I do
what am I supposed to do, she said we're in the bridge, yeah we're in the bridge, do something
did you prevent, oh okay, okay I see how it is
next to the main view screen, the main view screen, there isn't a main view screen, everything's destroyed
I leave home for a few days and look what happens, this won't take long
there, that should give us enough time to make it to a lifeboat and put some distance between ourselves and the people before the dead nation
I'm not actually under the quote, oh hell
you wouldn't view a warship's AI with such a wealth of knowledge, weren't you worried it might be captured or destroyed
he's in my data arrays, a local tab
you can't imagine how exciting this is to have a record of all of our lost time
human history isn't fascinating
huh
You cannot win! Give us the construct, and I will endeavor to make your death relatively famous, and...
At least I still have control over the comm channels.
Where is he?
I'm detecting taps throughout the ship. Sentinels most likely. As for the monitor...
He's an engineering. He must be trying to take the core offline.
Even if I could get the countdown restarted, I don't know what to do.
How much firepower would you need to crack one of the engine shields?
Not much. A well-placed grenade, perhaps, but why...
But why? And he's instantly, like, fucking tossing that shit.
Okay, I'm coming with you.
Yeah, you're...
Sentinels.
We're not leaving our brain.
What was learning about humanity?
The basic of muster-up is fascinating.
Okay, we good? We good?
Hang out a little cheeky-heel?
Uh, I assume back the way I came, somehow?
Well, the music started up, so I'm gonna take that as a use.
Right.
I don't know what to say. I'm a bit speechless right now.
I don't know.
Alright, we're getting it, we're getting it, we're getting it, we're getting it.
Don't worry, we're not, we're not quitting or anything like that.
I'm just a bit out of words in terms of, like...
You know...
Let's wrap it up.
I'm not even bothering to fight.
I will happily move on.
Nope.
It just seems like the best way to do it is to just fucking bash past it.
Sorry.
I'm enjoying this game, I'm just a bit like...
The backtracking through the same maps, the getting confused, where the heck are we heading, where the heck are we going?
It's a bit like, oh my god, wrap it up, please, I'm happy, I'm happy, we're gonna win, I'm happy, you know...
We got the halo rings and all that ting, but...
Oh my god, please wrap it up, I'm dying.
I'm actually dying.
Like, I enjoyed when everything was new, but is that...
I think there's three back-to-back maps that we've played, and we've just gone and repeated them.
And I don't mean to be nasty, I'm so...
Like, I do enjoy Halo, don't get me wrong, enjoy the concept, it's very nostalgic because my dad used to play this.
And, you know, poggers and all that, but...
I'm getting a bit...
I assume this is the way to go considering they're like, unending.
You're doing good, okay, I hope so, I hope it's not bad.
Wait, was that a health pack or something?
Yeah, it is.
How did I miss that?
Is this an infinite spawn or something?
They don't seem to be ending.
Am I accidentally found an infinite spawn?
I have.
Okay, well, that explains it.
Lucky me that that's what I freaking discovered.
Okay, I have none of that.
Can we please close this fucking door?
Checkpoint done, apparently?
I didn't do anything.
I'm glad you think I've done something, but I haven't.
I don't...
Oh, I can't get over by that.
Who are they shooting at?
This is like...
Wait, all I'm saying is that when I go to bed tonight, I'm watching...
Combat Evolved Legendary, because what the eff is this?
And I'm so...
I don't know where to go.
That was the way forward.
Am I going backward?
I'm supposed to go in here.
Sorry, I'm so sorry, darlings.
Forgive me, forgive me.
I just don't know where to go.
Hold on.
Wait, that was the way forward.
What was the way forward there?
You haven't earned your stripes from this one.
Wait, back here where everything was locked off, it opened a door when it said checkpoint reached.
Oh my...
Wait, did it?
No.
I'm so sorry.
Ah, sorry.
I can hear them.
At least if you're going to attack me, at least give me a...
Oh, I'm going to lose.
I'm trying, and I'm going to dead.
Okay, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
I have tons of needs for a reason.
Did he just...
Wait, where did you come from?
That thing just spawned, and she...
See, if I spawned behind, it's perfectly fine, but...
Because it's not me, is this where I came from?
No, I just saw my 360.
I just felt like...
I just felt like sailing on them, sorry.
Oh, yeah, okay, yeah, that's where they respawn over there, right?
Where am I coming? Where am I going?
Where did you come from? Where did you come from?
Engine room open, we're here.
Alert, the monitor has disabled all command access.
We can't restart the countdown.
The only remaining option is to detonate the ship's fusion reactors.
That should do enough damage to destroy Halo.
Don't worry, I have access to all of the reactor schematics and procedures.
I'll walk you through it.
First, we need to pull back the exhaust covers.
That will expose a shaft that leads to the primary fusion drive core.
Expose a shaft?
I do that on the daily, ma'am.
Right.
Y'all gonna need to stop.
Or you're gonna make me drop.
Wait, well, where?
Where? Stop.
It's telling me.
Sorry.
I'm not supposed to be here.
No, I'm not supposed to be here. Sorry.
Where am I?
I can hear him. We'll...
I don't know. It says...
You will destroy this installation as well as this fascinating record.
Yes.
Fusion reactor number one destabilizing.
Use explosives on the other three reactors.
That should be enough to trigger a Wildcat explosion of the engines.
I'm waiting for her to tell me.
Wait.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I get it. I get it. I get it. I get it. I get it. I get it.
Okay, we're almost done. We're almost done.
We're almost there. Almost there. Almost there.
Almost there.
Oh.
So, we're to just go around in circles. Got it.
Hello.
What do you want?
I still need.
It wasn't deep enough?
I guess not.
I guess it wasn't deep enough.
Wait till they open. You can do it.
Basically, you have to get to this thing with the hole and throw a heat in it.
Honestly.
Okay, how do I do the third one?
Ow. Got burnt a little bit and I'll go on. That kind of hurt.
So, run for the monster to me.
Or I'll be forced to take you up my head.
No.
I need to do it any more or am I done?
Keep it up. Only one more fusion reactor to go.
Okay, and then surely that's it, right? Surely.
I'm not going to be asked to do anything else from this game.
It's quite a miracle.
Surely, I'm not going to be asked anything else.
Not a singular thing else.
Uh-huh.
No war.
Mm-hmm.
There's a service lift at the top of the engine room.
It leads to a class 7 service corridor that runs along the ship's dorsal structure.
Hurry!
Where am I to go?
That way?
Gimli? Is that you?
Did my cat just meow?
Where am I to go?
Is this to go up?
I don't know where I'm to go.
Gimli, are you in this room? No, I'm not.
You just got to stay on top of the thing.
Oh.
So, I'm going the complete wrong way. We're right at the third second.
15 minutes is plenty of time to make it.
Yes, but it's me that's playing, which is a problem, refund.
For an average gamer, absolutely. For me?
Right, I need to go up 4-3 for it.
Fly-full. Send it a little like a meow, but could it be me?
I heard a big meow.
I thought it might be Gimli.
Oh, is this how it did end? We went up earlier? I think it is as well.
Look behind me.
What's this? A lift?
I don't see her.
Okay.
I'm sure we'll get there in 2 minutes.
Woah, this is rough.
I have been hearing me out. That's weird.
Catcams? Okay. I'm doing a pulp in the chicken stream.
And I'm really...
Gimli and Bebo can't come on.
And the Lord that Elite has been chasing you since the game started to tell you.
We need stuff. Put it to bags.
Put it to bags. Put it to bags.
He's an assassin.
Timer, do it!
I can't handle it.
Can I not get in a warhold?
We can't make it on foot. We need a vehicle.
Okay, well, I'll try it.
Oh my god, there's an actual timer.
I think I'm going to be doing this segment again.
Get in the warhold. Okay, let's go.
Um...
Why would the last mission require driving?
Are they serious?
They really just said we hate our female chicken fan base.
What the fuck?
I don't know if it's better to go down and up
or if it's to stay on this weird winding path.
I don't know.
I mean, we've cleared 1.5.
Avoid dying?
I'd already be dead if that was legendary, because what was that?
I don't even know how to take this much damage.
Uh, hold on. I need to pick it up again.
Okay.
The driver's seat, Master Chief.
The driver's seat.
My stomach isn't strong enough for this.
Close your eyes, darling. Close your eyes.
It's not looking good.
Are these put there on purpose?
I swear.
If they're put there on purpose for that reason alone,
literally what even is that?
I...
You've got to avoid them. Why would they even put those in?
That's so malicious and evil.
I'm gonna have to replay this entire section again.
Like, what is this map?
Leo!
Plain fucking dodge arms in a corridor?
I don't even know what the most efficient way of getting through these locations would be.
Because you can't even send it in the middle.
They've got all these weird things in the way.
Yeah, and if you miss, you lose all your momentum.
Is that what it's supposed to be? You're rewarded for doing it perfectly,
but if you miss your momentum, it's over?
What the fuck? Thanks, man!
I think I can get past without dying, right?
Okay.
100 meters away, at least.
A Christmas miracle.
Nope.
Yeah, no, I'm sorry, but why is it open?
Wait, I still only have two minutes you didn't add to my timer?
It didn't add to my timer?
Have I lost this burial?
Have I lost?
Huh?
I don't know if I'm winning or not!
I don't know if I'm winning.
This is getting a bit too close for Malaykin.
I guess.
Am I supposed to fucking manually walk the rest of it? I guess!
Oh my god. Get me on this fucking thing.
Please, don't kill me now.
Oh my god, we did it. I don't have to do that again.
Oh.
That was awful. Don't ever let me do that again.
Oh my god.
First try, I'll actually, in zero deaths, run, zero allies, hit, run.
Something tells me the flood isn't over.
Oh.
We're in space.
Cortana. Oh, we blew it up.
Oh, we blew up the whip? Oh, we blew it up. Yeah, okay, I get it.
Oh.
Fancy a look? It's not really.
Only 17 deaths and seven allies. No.
Thank you, Justice John, for becoming a member.
You enjoyed that move?
So we broke the weapon.
No.
Yes, one tells me the flood comes back.
Oh, he's taking his helmet off.
Did you know when he takes his helmet off, it just stays on?
Okay, Sergeant Johnson made it.
He was the part of the alien. How did he make it?
No hologram girlfriend to justify my war crimes?
Real? What's under the helmet?
Another cliffhanger? There's a second game?
Isn't there like five healers now?
Nah, he lives because he was spotted on there.
Oh, reluctantly saying thank you for the 10 gifts, memberships.
I'm sorry for being such a fucking miserable coward at the end of that.
Bro, wrap it up.
Oh my God, I was, that was like,
I'm not gonna lie, by like the third fetch quest
on the same map that I've already been on before.
Sorry, I'm taking off my heart rate monitor because I don't need it anymore.
It might make a beep though, just to warn you, hear a beep.
It's okay, we still enjoyed it, powering through, bro.
Oh, there it goes.
Am I going mental and saying like a fucking wrap up?
Thank you, reluctantly saying thanks.
For those who you caught it with your face, enjoy the email.
You know, it supports the channel.
Oh wow, that broke my motto for some reason, taking it off.
It's fair, that was a lot, don't worry about it.
I can't believe it, I'm heavily criticizing a game that was developed in 2001.
What a terrible person I am.
No way, you gave me a tip for every death.
I did it 16 times.
Thank you for the tip death, John Omne.
I appreciate you.
They didn't pretty much set the standard for fast shooters though.
Halo 2 is the best game.
Is Halo 2 better, right?
Maybe we'll play Halo 2 then.
Is there going to be scary things in Halo 2?
Is the flood coming back, to be honest?
Does the flood come back?
Oh my god, why is my YouTube studio all messed up?
My shells are getting cold, but they aren't cold.
Where am I?
Scary like FNAF?
No, flood won't be like that, no?
Maybe?
It was just the reveal of them.
And it was the worst part.
Oh my god, my boots were cut off.
You didn't say anything?
Anyway, thank you so much for playing Halo with me.
I had so much fun.
I don't know about you, but I really...
Could you imagine?
That's it.
Halo 2 is mental.
Is it like as long as that?
Or is it like better?
They had a limited budget on Halo 1.
As much as I'm complaining, I do have to admit,
considering the resources they most likely had,
what they could do, the budget,
what their console could do as well,
obviously would pay into the factors a lot.
There is no mention of the flood in any material,
even for the Covenant Guide to beat them,
there was nothing for the flood.
Why have all times that I decided to look up at that moment?
I don't know, maybe you knew I was up to some mischievous,
devious app.
There's a secret.
The development of Halo 3 was an absolute mess and rush
after its development team, then.
The game was a long time in development though.
I wondered, there was that scene where he yanked the thing from me,
and I was like,
was there supposed to be something in between that?
But then I was like, no.
But...
The development of Halo 2 was worse?
I thought 3, 4, 3 became Bungie or something like that.
I thought they got actually...
You should really check out the Halo marketing and trailers
that release this stuff.
I'm going to watch someone play Legendary tonight.
Legendary difficulty,
because how on Earth is anyone playing that Legendary?
I have no idea.
No, 3, 4, 3 got Halo from Bungie.
Oh, fun, right.
Right, okay.
Doom when?
You want me to play Doom?
Am I going to get annoyed at Doom though?
That's my concern.
If I'm going to get annoyed,
if I'm like, wrap it up, right, wrap it up.
That's when I get concerned,
because I'm like, no,
because I know I've turned into such a wee moody cow in that,
when I'm like, ah, wrap it up.
Perhaps.
Halo 2 Market was the scene.
7-Eleven slurping up.
Oh!
3, 4, 3 was created by Microsoft to keep Halo going,
but they...
But will she get annoyed at Doom?
Or Old School Doom or Doom 2016?
I don't know.
I take your guys' recommendation.
This is your choice, not mine.
If you're asking me to play Doom, I'll play Doom,
but you've been whined.
If you want to fight Capitals,
then BioShock might be mine.
BioShock 2 is on the roster this month at Layergate.
I will open up my little chandelier.
Boom.
Nope.
That's a meme.
That's not a schedule.
Hold on.
This is a schedule.
This is annoying.
Oh, no, that's me.
Okay.
We will do this.
So this week is focused on being a little bit smaller
whilst I deal with some background stuff.
We should have the clipper program launched though.
As for the longest day, I guess it's Friday
because it's four hours of RuneScape offline
and then two hours with Arisa.
But this week is going to be a little bit shorter
just because I'm trying to launch that program,
but you know, you need to sit down
and you need to get the website out.
You need to lay everything out
and make it super-duper easy for everyone involved.
So that's the shenanigans we plan on getting up to.
Doom Eternal took all of Doom 2016
and made it in Zoomer.
Hell!
Wait, does that mean I'm going to like it though?
Yes, we are going to launch an established clipper program
where we pay you
if you have an established clipping channel.
What's the money to put the girls?
Basically.
But I need to write down all the...
The website update, the thing...
Doom 1993 is one of my favourite games of all time.
Do we pixel one?
Vermintide 2, yes.
I'm going to get a throwaway Steam account.
I've been enjoying lurking here as I wake up.
Oh, am I a good time zone for you?
Play Oddworld Apes Odyssey.
I think there was a remake for it too.
It's difficult, but you're going to love the opening scene.
Play the game for the opening scene.
Turns into like a rage and mess by the end of it.
Apparently Turn It Boy commits to Activation.
I keep hearing it in the whispers for VTubers
and I'm like, is it a VTuber game?
I don't know, let's find out.
Right, is there any of my girls that are online
so I can redirect them to their cheeky bum?
I also want to do some of that 8 more,
so I will put the rooms up publicly.
I think I do have some meow.
Let me see.
Do I have a thumbnail?
What thumbnail do you want?
Okay, you know what?
This is the best thumbnail for next week.
I'm going to show you.
Oh my god, spoilers.
This is the best thumbnail for next week,
because it's adorable.
Are you ready for it?
Boom.
Escape Simulator with Icy.
And look, she has a monocle
and like a Fedoro hat,
or what are they called?
A Fedoro?
I forgot the name, a Fedoro.
And then I got a little paper and a little magnifying glass.
Yeah, VTuber assets are kinda hitting the gritty.
They're really good.
But yeah, I think that's the best thumbnail of this.
Or maybe, maybe this one, hold on.
Oh my god, I'm just leaking all the thumbnails
before I put them out.
Are you ready?
Are you steady?
I'll show you this.
Boom.
Me?
Why am I wanted for tax evasion?
I get taxed extra,
because I'm a foreigner in this country.
Yay.
I love paying a tax based on the fact that I didn't spawn here.
Yippee.
I think you just love it.
Shotting behavior.
Right, let's see if any of my girls are on.
Emmy's on.
Oh my god, we can redirect into Emmy.
Oh, she did a Bob Ross stream.
That's fantastic.
Oh my god, where is her hair?
Where is her hair?
Her hair is gone.
Oh my god.
She took her fucking hair off.
Are you just making me right now?
Oh my god, that's hilarious.
That's funny to look.
She's Bob Ross.
Anonymous, thank you for the 25.
You didn't say anything.
No, and don't tip saying something
or nothing in the message or whatever.
Thank you for the 25.
Anonymous, that's very kind of you.
You know, you don't have to be shy.
You can talk to me in Marcell or something.
Oh, it's so quiet.
Giving me money quietly when I'm with Chad.
Whenever someone gives me something quietly,
everyone's like, what Chad?
What Chad?
And it's like, maybe he's just too scared to talk to me.
I don't know.
Don't be scared, Evelyn.
Either way, you're getting milked.
It was a great stream.
You enjoyed it.
I'm glad.
That was fun.
I didn't realize how hard Halo could be, though.
I thought it was easy for you to make sure again.
But we did it.
We did it.
Think fried something.
Anonymous, reward paid.
You are free.
What does that mean?
Reward paid.
I'm free.
Okay, I am going to go get a bath
because I reek of deodorant
after discovering what the flood...
No, I don't reek of deodorant.
I reek of body odor after discovering what the flood is.
So I'll see you in the bath, okay?
Yeah.
We can brain-rotten the bath together on TikTok.
How about that, Evelyn?
I'll put my lemon soap bar in as well,
so it smells nice.
The pheromone maxing.
Yeah, unfortunately, pheromones are going
because it's that stinky kind of feel.
You know how sometimes you can get a whiff for yourself
and you're like, oh, that's a wee bit stinky?
No, this is vile.
If you were to take a whiff, you'd gag.
Please bottle and sell to me.
Honestly, though.
Right, thank you so, so much,
my little rufflings for enjoy.
I just realized my heart rate is still displaying,
even though it's not.
Thank you so, so much for enjoying.
Please enjoy.
Amy Beezoo.
I will see you tomorrow
for some shenanigans with sin,
and then a membership stream.
And then we'll take it from there for the week, okay?
But hopefully I have some exciting news for the snowberries
when it comes to an AC role play,
as well for the reeflings
because my collab with Sage
that I never shut up about
because it never comes out,
but it's coming out soon.
Promise.
I just need to do a few background things, as always.
Wow, I can't believe it.
I can't believe I'm doing a YouTuber agency.
Takes a little bit of extra time.
Who'd you think, huh?
Who'd you think?
Amy Beezoo.
Thank you so much for joining
Heal Combat Evolved with me.
I'm so surprised we somehow survived
that car mission with the Warthog,
but we did it, okay?
And I'll see you tomorrow.
Um...
Mwah.
I'm gonna kiss ten times
because there's two killers and eight survivors tomorrow.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Nine.
Ten.
Kisses.
Please enjoy Amy to your fullest content
with her Bob Ross hair,
which is terrifying.
But she's enjoying herself,
so that's the main thing.
Okay.
Bye-bye.
I see you tomorrow.
Mwah.